there's tomatoes in the chat
and the dislike button is being smashed
well guys i have to first of all thank
you for being here happy friday i have
to warn you guys we learned that if you
hit the dislike button you may not see
our videos
why
yeah exactly really we were watching the
video about um them getting rid of the
dislike button and the guy said you can
still use the dislike button
and we'll take that
you know signal
to affect your recommendations no
signals
so guys put that heard that dislike
button really hurts me
no signals
you may not see our podcast in fact i'm
going to urge you guys maybe to even
like the video at this point which i've
never done in my career as a youtuber
because apparently liking the videos you
probably have done it
well
hey guys welcome to the podcast please
like and subscribe
so i'm going to have to start doing that
now please like
[Music]
uh god i don't know what happened to be
my i'm like blotchy um i've got like a
crazy blotch here you got like a rash
all over your beard under my beard it's
so itchy i'm itchy all over my body i
don't know what happened to me i'm
melding
and blotching we found out that he used
some kind of face wash last night that i
think was too old i think we've had it
for like a couple two or three years i
didn't think that stuff went bad i don't
know but maybe just face wash
well it did mess me up
look how blotchy i am i'm a freak you
guys don't look at me
has anyone got a paper heart has anyone
got a paper bag i can wear over my head
[Music]
it's not that bad though
yeah you're being nice
and so it's all under your beard you
can't even no but this part bothers me
this blotchy spot here
i gotta see a dermatologist or something
freak
anyway today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn and raycon thank you we got a
really fun episode today
check in with a b by the way today is
the judge is going to be deciding
[Applause]
if the
conservatorship is being
cancelled
i didn't know that really yeah well a b
if you can if you can go over to a b um
he's there live on the scene waiting for
the announcement
a b
we've got a on live we got a live
recording
live action h3 action news that's the
same testing
coming in loud buddy
how's it going are you just on your
phone man
i am on my phone but i have a good
microphone good mic the sound is great
the audio is pretty crap but the audio
is great
yeah you in the video the video what did
you say
listen you guys you gotta read between
the lines everyone knew what i meant
wow there's lots of excitement there's a
lot of people tell us about the uh yeah
tell us what's going on there
so me and olivia just got here
can i have you excuse me if i cut myself
off good good maybe olivia should hold
the phone eh
hi olivia like why why is she there if
not to help
no she was holding the phone we were
having problems switching it around
yeah evie's like thank you
i'm just gonna hold this and
it's gonna look anyway that's that's
much better
yeah a lot of people out here for
brittany
a lot of people dressed as brittany
oh
stations
how's the energy down there people
feeling optimistic
it seems optimistic
you want to interview hopefully the
tides don't change let's get some let's
get some interviews going
yeah i'm trying to find some interesting
characters well find the go talk to the
dude with the big ass sign
all right that's probably your best bet
you're honest
[Laughter]
olivia said i'm nervous i'm not nervous
but i can't
maybe you can do this man i believe in
you
cutting
cutting edge stuff here guys
he is running around
i'm surprised how come the video is so
poor i mean
that would be t-mobile oh you think you
think the
4g network is getting sapped
yeah that's why you need to uh get uh
mobile
okay thank you good plug
yeah find someone with the sign ab okay
all right
we have some britney impersonators
one second
that worked okay but i'm not going to
hear you guys
okay go ahead let's get yes
going to the furthest possible person in
the crowd maybe maybe let him go find
somebody set it up no this is
interesting i like this
okay
so
how's it going
would you guys be interested in doing a
quick interview of course okay so my
name is a.b i'm here from the h3 podcast
no how are you guys good how are you
good so what's going on here today so i
am zach zilla and these are the lovely
britney spears that we love so much um
yeah so i have a song called hashtag
free britney and i just want to be a
part of the movement um it's about human
rights and you know messages whatever
you love to do is your superpower
whether that be artist dancing i think
britney spears can we get an example
it's your power that's being a sale is
all about and uh yeah we just want to
join the movement this is really fun and
lively yeah can he
be can he say
he can't hear me he can't hear us why is
that he can oh so the host of the show
wants to know if you give a sample real
quick yeah your song yeah
okay uh
acapella
yeah
you can perform it yeah that guy's not
wearing he's wearing do you wanna
all right here we go
what are we doing uh we'll actually like
just
dance you guys do want to do the
breakdown
yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna do that we're gonna
dance okay then give us a breakdown
there we go all right it's exciting free
brittany
okay they're preparing for this
breakdown
baby seven eight bam [ __ ]
hit it hit it they're saying one more
time
they're in sync this is beautiful i'm
loving what i'm seeing
damn
does anyone else think that dude looks
like onion
that was awesome
i wish they could have got some of the
audio on that
beautiful britney
queen and pop we stand our dream is stay
free again
show your love for brittany
it's a pop emergency 9-1-1 yeah we can
save the girl who made us dance all
around the world like that
maybe tell them what's your name one
more time my name is zach zilla zach
exactly
thank you so much thank you so much
ladies thank you tell them
tell them there's 27 000 people watching
i want them to know that there's 27
people 27 000 people watching right now
he's not impressed
let you guys know that 27 000 live
viewers just saw you guys perform oh my
god thank you so much
thank you so much all right guys
thank you we just gave him he said he
loves how shady we are so maybe he
doesn't know who we are
um
here's what i want to do but uh olivia
is going to give me your messages
oh sh you can oh so olivia
here's what i want to do guys
when you find someone interesting or
something to show you you you okay she's
not in your head all right let's just
yeah when he's nodding so keep your chat
when you find something interesting tell
dan and we'll bring you guys back on
okay
okay good thank you guys thanks for the
reporting you guys are doing great we
got a time
that's pretty exciting we got a live
report up there very exciting what a
thrill
i love it
little dancing a little singing to start
us off on friday
that's exciting i'm sure there's gonna
be other exciting things so the
conservatorship is going bye bye this
britney is free to be
hopefully right oh speaking of uh
a free legend gabe
what's
gabe what's going on this friday
i just got new tires
okay that's pretty good
nice michelin charge the best yep the
best tires there is
how big is the ride when i get michelin
tires
what's the size it's big
yes
it's the premier l
xto
do you know what the
tire
do you know what the air pressure is
inside there
[Music]
dude i don't know why but no no
connections aren't working today yeah
today's the day of bad connections it's
one of those days all right gabe well
thanks for calling in we love you we we
know i don't have to wish you a happy
friday i know you're gonna have a great
friday
all right
all right gabe you take care buddy
thanks for checking in okay you keep
crushing out there you have a great
weekend
all right love you buddy gabe white
clock gave everybody on cameo and
everywhere you can find him
something in the air blocking the uh
yeah the signals today
i think it's the uh vaccine
oh you think the 5g vaccine is yep
we're all too vaccinated in here yep
bro give me i i want that 5g as whatever
makes the internet work for them i'll
take
yeah so a little bit of a plug here at
the top of the show tomorrow's our teddy
fresh pop-up
as we kind of discussed we're not going
to be there we had to cancel because we
don't want pregnant hila to get covered
and i know with the meet and greet
there's going to be lots of hugging and
shaking hands which i love i would love
to do we
i just feel like that's what it's about
like otherwise why would you do a meet
and greet if you have to like stand
behind a flat plexiglass and you just
it's prison hi
so but i i am really sad that we can't
do that but i hope that everybody still
goes because the event is going to be
really cool really awesome the event is
going to be amazing
it's tomorrow from 12 to 8. the address
is here on the flyer on all of our
social medias 4441 sunset boulevard and
you're going to get the looney tunes
4441 sunset boulevard yeah
i mean
it's possible i read it wrong though so
not to get defensive
yeah um you're going to get the looney
tunes collection a week early there's
going to be free food with purchases
from
uh monty's monty
vegan burger it's beloved here in l.a
yeah and then this is also called this
activation the spray paint we've posted
the gentle thrills is going to be doing
free
spray painting
[Applause]
or heat transfers we got both
she's so cool i love her oh she's so
cool yeah she is so cool she really is
and that's like really cool yeah um and
there's gonna be nails i did it on
myself to show
are you gonna post that on the social me
the teddy fresh social media because i
want to but yeah um i was supposed to
take pictures with abe oh [ __ ] okay i
got it um
so these are like teddy fresh
little decals that you can get on your
nails
so it's gonna be a fun event i hope you
guys make it i'm sorry we won't be there
though um anyway by the way also you
want to show off the one of the pieces
yes because this is kind of the first
might be my favorite one except for the
jacket but
it's
taz
a different pattern
sick so airplane go down a little bit
yeah right there
there you go
how sick is that
nice
beautiful well anyway
teddy fresh yadda yadda this jacket is
live today by the way if you like the
one i'm wearing this is already on the
website okay thank you that's enough
vlogging
well actually now we have these articles
about you it's too much plugging let's
wait until the end okay i uh i'm being
informed that we have a uh old man ready
for interview bring them all for god's
sake all right stand by here i'm gonna
ask about you right now
so we are going back to our live
reporter abe who's on the streets of the
freedom hey guys i'm here today with mr
great donovan hello kids would you like
to tell us a little about who you are
and why you're here today yeah i was the
former goodwill ambassador for beverly
hills i used to see several celebrities
including brittany shopping and so on
and i
it just touches home um now today's
historical day and she's
i believe this is the day they're going
to end the conservatorship so
and it's not just for britney it's for
the whole world
because people that are taking advantage
of now it's kind of opened their eyes
right
so i had to be here i took the day off
have you been a british fan for a long
time well i i i i
i always admire the music i got
i'm not a big big fan super fan but i'm
i am a fan what's the significance of
his house and i had to come here just to
support
some of the organizers right it's more
about the convert conservatorships in
general exactly
outfit anything you like to say
yeah outfit free britney this is the day
and it asks about that outfit it's the
end of conservatory ship abuse
oh yeah these were designed for me many
uh brooks brothers briony
uh
battalia several because when i was in
beverly hills and i i own the image
uh if i look familiar i've been doing
this over 22 years from beverly hills
now i'm in hollywood and um
and yeah so it's yeah this is uh yeah
it's uh
oh wow very nice
he seems kind of like a fake fan though
i'm just curious
let's read the sign for christ's sake
expose corrupt los angeles county
probate court remove the free britney
what's under there
yeah
somebody gave that to me i don't know
the whole details
i want to read it anyway i want to read
it he's covering something i was a big
fan
very sweet if you guys are wondering why
i'm holding my hands like this it's
because my hands get shaky so
just so you know but nothing let's get
back to brittany don't worry there's not
enough resolution to see your handshake
thank you
all right take care
interesting characters down there today
a b being one of them
i can't believe that guy exposed himself
that quickly thank you
not a fan of brittany oh lovebots going
april over there he's more about the
movement like you said
he seems to have a specific issue with
the probation
whatever happened to her should not
happen to anyone
it's estimated
jesus christ
well dan can't move i know that i'm
logged
all
in
yeah
sorry about that
[Laughter]
all right let's try to actually so by
the way regarding um
yesterday's thumbnail we had a nice
little click bait
and i kind of want to reveal the
backstory behind that because there's
always really interesting stories here
behind our clickbait guys we don't just
click bait indiscriminately right it's
actually very sophisticated so this one
is i had to get emergency surgery
and you guys are going to love this
so here's the inspiration from the ace
family
check this out
look at this
same isn't that awesome
revealing my new body ma'am mommy
makeover nailed it mommy makeover in
reality you guys got scammed
four weeks ago she's wait is she really
just doing arm lipo
that's awesome
you think they have better things to
spend their money on like i know
this is an elective this is not a urgent
surgery
i need that clout it's mommy makeover
day today guys i am lipoing out of my
arms it's my beautiful new makeover
[Laughter]
so that's fun
yeah just a little explanation there but
um we're gonna continue the surgery saga
next week i'm really excited about what
we're working on
big plans the surgery saga
you say or clickbait saga oh well we
clickbaited that i was getting surgery
oh okay but we're continuing that story
yeah and i don't want to spoil it i i
shouldn't even brought it up but i'm
really excited okay
god my beard is so itchy ela what the
[ __ ]
what's happening to me there's something
we can get you to put on there but why
am i like
why am i
why am i just happening
some serious asmr going on with the
rubbing the beard under the mic yeah
it's kind of nice
well i'm in pain glad it's enjoying you
are you glad you're liking it
i'm dying
olivia says they have somebody else on
standby already
okay
i think i need a way to communicate with
abe for this to really work yeah
we should um without revealing the sauce
too much um that
that was happening just prior to going
live so i'm not uh exactly sure why
we're having if we can get a phone up to
abey's ear
with me talking i think what happened he
gave the phone to olivia and the
headphones are connected to that no it's
well it's wireless is it um yeah so well
let's get them to work on that before
they bring out the next person
okay i'll do it to master whatever plan
you guys uh all right mastermind right
sounds good in the meantime
dude check this out i got this hey you
need beard oil beard oil yeah
otherwise your skin gets all [ __ ] up
if you don't get beard oil
i gotta lube my beard dan you have a
baby i think it's
in it's whatever this old product you
used last night i think it just
irritated your skin
do you what's your beard regiment dan
and ian
uh i i do have some beard oil that was
gifted to me at one point um and i do
have to say that it
you know i like once a week or something
i'll kind of like after i shave
spread it through a little bit but i i
believe it's to moisturize the beard
itself not the skin underneath i use
normal moisturizer for for the skin how
do you get under the beard the
moisturizer
what i don't really i mean yeah you
don't yeah yeah
a couple people are just saying you need
benadryl aloe vera i think i'm having an
allergic reaction yeah [ __ ]
can i get can i make an admission too
and
i don't want you to read too far into
this but my dick really itches too and i
don't see that
different
issue but obviously i don't have any
like grab venereal diseases wait did you
use the same product
maybe your body i don't
no no nothing happened but it's like
it's all my whole body is reacting you
know you get that crotch rot stop it are
you having a crush
[Laughter]
it's okay to come forward if you got
cross ready
the last time this happened is when i
got poison ivy on my junk it's not that
bad but it reminds me of that
could it be crouched
i don't know where i would have got
crabs from
one of you guys didn't hear about crabs
and crawled over to me
crab is just like lice right so like why
would i have a pubic life dan
the one with the [ __ ] itchy ass beard
and [ __ ] pubes i don't know what to
say
i'm here and i go home i got sexually
interested one of you guys we don't have
that kind of concept look at your little
uh bird nest on your face this one's got
a little mushroom and it's you know my
[ __ ] ain't hit you it's either i should
have
long hair are these two long beard so uh
we gotta make the distinction
you got any crabs in
not that i'm aware of my beard's smooth
man
yeah
we're smooth sailing over here this this
side of the room
maybe it's part of the uh bug
infestation we've been having maybe crap
all right i am hearing that the audio
issues have been released okay exciting
by the way it is 136 the hearing is at 1
30 so we could be hearing big news at
any moment what a thrill what a thrill
we've got our audio issues resolved okay
let's talk to some of the interesting
characters out there
a b
live on the scene
yes can you hear me
yes i'm with you now
okay i'm here with alexandra who's a
fellow foot soldier hello let's go what
brittany what's going on
[Applause]
so why are you here today i am here to
support free brittany this is the end of
the conservatory
can i ask i'm a huge brainy spears fan
huge can you hear me now i can hear you
yeah okay great yeah if brittany is not
free can we expect riots flipping cars
fires what can we expect here bernie is
not afraid do you expect riots moving
cars uh
i don't expect riots a
does not get terminated today people
will be pissed off i will be pissed off
can we flip some police cars for pledge
to me to flip some police cars ethan
wants to know if you could put some
police cars can i flip oh boy don't test
me
[Laughter]
well
we appreciate her enthusiasm and we love
oh i her
you
thanks for making me laugh
absolutely thank you
anytime what let me see her shirt there
let me okay let's just move on
it's hard
okay all right well thank you guys all
right
cool
lots of excitement out there for
brittany
um
i just got this ad on to oh but i want i
want to say something else
go for it
oh the bts a b made another bts right
that's life for members and it's really
good
he's been taking little videos
throughout the week
and uh it's really fun so for members we
have an extra perk
live for you guys right now weekly bts
thank you boom
so thank you to our members
i was just surfing tick tock right
before the show and i got this joe rogan
on it ad and i was like holy [ __ ] man
this is awesome
joe loves it get the edge that you need
swipe left before it sells out again
really
these [ __ ] trying to tell me
that alpha brain's selling out
isn't it just like sawdust putting a
little capsule how does that sell out i
think there's some catnip in there right
catnip i mean that's all readily
available
belly button lint
it's 100 legit if i go to a ufc and i
don't have alpha brain i panic i take it
before every podcast i even oftentimes
take it on the air just to let people
know i really take this one of the
immediate things that i noticed was that
i had a better recall of words it's 100
legit if if i go to a uf
there you have it that makes no sense i
just love that he's hawking this [ __ ] i
mean this is the guy who's who's
encouraging people not to get vaccinated
and at the same time he wants you to
take an un regulated
not approved brain supplement that as
far as i know has uh you know
asbestos pcp dust
and [ __ ] uh they won the nobel prize
oh really the the active ingredient is
actually wrap poop and
uh uh
toenail clippings
ground up into a fine powder and you can
definitely trust his unbiased
recommendation considering he's only the
co-founder of the company is he the
co-founder i know he's like invest he's
not the co-founder that's what google
says well clearly he's like a chemist
he's a co-founder of on it and probably
its most famous spokesperson this is on
on its way he's the co-founder wow that
is on on it.com so oh that's that's
weird
this gives me like t martin promoting
csgo gambling vibes
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's like as you know i am well i have
my phd in uh bro ology
what kind of drug enhances your
performance like right immediately
like your mental capacity yeah nothing
that doesn't exist like literally
nothing if it did we'd all be taking it
i guarantee that you know [ __ ]
fraudulent well we actually made you
know i remember we made dan our guinea
pig for a while because i tried it for a
month uh i could not notice any
difference at all but my brain is so
[ __ ]
finely tuned already like it's just like
a perfectly operating oiled machine
right that i don't it it may have more
effect on on
people
dumb asses like me yeah i didn't want to
say it but yeah morons
you know
and there are a lot of those in joe
rogan's audience so i get it oh yeah
wait hold on you know what i look like
after i take alphabet
once i take out for brain
this is what happens to me
oh all capsules of alpha brain are oh
your brain enters the matrix i don't
think
ascension meme
oh
i can recall no rogan podcast yeah
you got any joe rogan soundbites to
improve this go go go back to dan
experience
[Music]
alpha brain
eat eat elk made only
yes so
obviously again he he's well qualified
to formulate
supplements to improve your brain so
that's cool
yeah i didn't know he's the co-founder
it's a little sassy a little sassy bacca
oh and then there's a new you know we
keep talking about how disney does these
goofy edits where it's like it's the
first time for me
yeah they've done like five of them and
they just dropped a new one
they're just doing it intentionally now
yeah to get like
us to talk about
yeah did you hear that one the aquafina
i did
i think what they're doing is they're
just running tight little spots for ads
yeah or social clips so they they cut
them down
so they're longer
[Music]
still think they would specifically
shoot a short one for the short one yes
you would think that
well here's the new one
there's a hunger for this character to
come down
there is a hunger for this character
there's character but
there's not really a need to remove the
quarter second of space there dude this
is because this is an hour or a minute
40 video
there's a hunger to remove that
hunger for this car this guy
[Music]
there's a hunger for this character to
come back
[Music]
the fans have been waiting long enough
from this
wait i thought they canceled the obi-wan
series
well well there's out there for the
audience
i'm sure
uh ian's a way better person to answer
this though because he's the prequel
stan uh here in the office so i i mean
are you hyped to see ob back uh i mean
he's cool i saw
one of the concept arts is him fighting
darth vader which
seems kind of weird because how does
that happen that's not canon is it well
if they're gonna just shoehorn that in i
don't know that does seem kind of weird
because they only follow marching they
thought and the original and darth he
let darth kill him
there there's a there's a time frame
where that could happen
what's your hunger levels
ian
um
appetite's not that way that big on this
one
hunger for the
for the character
i was like wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
hold the phone
we're eating kenobi's
kenobi's yeah
cannolis
yeah
hunger for this character
come back it doesn't even sound like him
it's so [ __ ] cut up yeah i'm not like
really bad youtube editing it's like
[ __ ] perry mason or some [ __ ] you
know it's like an intern just cut
chopped it up real fast this how does
this make sense this doesn't make sense
they didn't fight like this did they
well i mean there's a huge gap between
the prequels and the and the original
trilogy right so again they'll just find
a way to make it happen from like 30
years i think between
so when they meet again in the future
it's kind of like i think it's less
that's a name i haven't heard a long
time it seems like obi was consistently
beating his ass though in the movies and
the only reason darth ever beat him was
because he let him kill him
uh right well and he's really old by
then
not this one though he should beat his
[ __ ] ass in this one cam saying it's
only 19 years from yeah i was about to
say it's got to be less because
luke is born at the end of the prequels
and then he's like a teenager in the
original movies or like 20 or something
right so no fighting in that
[Music]
yeah but like ob is old as [ __ ] like
well he he ages a lot it's 20 years
but he's jedi so like isn't that like a
different aging process that's true
all right nerd i'm so out on this
conversation
let's move on
i just wanted to show the goofy sound
thoughts hunger
[Laughter]
um believe it or not we are how no
we didn't even talk about it we don't
have anything yeah it's 30 33 minutes
all right it's gonna be a long episode
guys
also just right before you do that an
update is that
everyone is expecting the verdict at 2
45 so we're actually a ways out from now
we have an hour that's good to look
forward to okay well let's thank our
sponsors today expressvpn
um every time
you connect to an encrypted network cafe
hotel or airport any hacker on the same
network can gain access to your personal
data i'm talking about passwords
financial details
uh
you know pictures of your deck
just saying just saying
saying
it doesn't take much technical knowledge
to hack someone either just some cheap
hardware is all you need a smart 12 year
old could do it and your data is really
valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling your
personal info on the dark web spooky
so why so you know why use expressvpn
it's like an encrypted tunnel you create
a secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet hackers can't
steal your sensitive data it's super
secure it takes a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption and that's
easy to use fire up the app click one
button and you're protected it works on
all devices phones laptops tablets and
more so you can stay safe and secure on
the go you don't have to think about it
dude thank you crowder yeah i mean
expressvpn's awesome it's the best one
it's the best one in the game
like they said if you're traveling it
helps you feel keep safe your isp can't
be snooping on you and you can access
content in other countries
let's be honest that's awesome
oh yeah
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
after dark that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn
dot com slash after dark and you can get
an extra three months for free that's
expressvpn.com
after dark also i forgot to read the
intro so here it is using the internet
without expressvpn is like leaving your
laptop exposed at a coffee shop while
you run into the bathroom most of the
time you're probably fine but if one day
you come out of the bathroom and your
laptop is gone
okay
no there you go just so they can't come
back thank you
and thank you finally to raycon my boy
it's never too early to start gift
shopping for the holidays especially
because today you can save big on a gift
they'll use every day it's the raycon
wireless earbuds
[Music]
you know what use it for working from
home taking your workouts outdoors going
for walks listening without you know
being disturbed you know why people use
earbuds
yeah
you can use it for all those reasons
well either
with a seamless bluetooth pairing and a
comfortable noise isolating fit you can
start listening right away and keep
listening for hours the audio quality is
amazing compared to what you get from
other premium brands you know except
raycon starts at just half the price
and the new everyday earbuds come with
three new sound profiles to make sure
everything you're listening to sounds is
best with just the right amount of bass
you got pure mode for podcast blues
instrumental you got balanced mode for
rock heavy you know heavy metal bass
mode for hip hop edm reggae raycon
offers eight hours of play time and 32
hour battery life there's also a
built-in mic so you can take calls on
your earbuds at the press of a button so
this holiday season get them something
they can use for calls or music or work
or play at home or on the go or pick up
a pair yourself because trust me you're
gonna love them you're gonna use them
every day they're comfortable they're
just as good as anything out there and
it's half the price so go to buy
raycon.com h3ad today to unlock
exclusive deals of 20 off your recon
order but hurry this offer is only
available for a limited time only and
you don't want to miss it that's by
raycom.com h3ad to unlock up to 20 off
your raycons that's by raycon.com
h3ad thank you peace and
nailed
love
all right what's this going 60 miles per
hour on the
highway
you didn't see this yet
wait a minute he's on the hot what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean it's a hell of a way to get
around
i see those things all over town now
they don't go that fast no
[Music]
just imagine crashing
you're dead yeah you're absolutely dead
yeah
he's not even covering his skin like
he just knows she's like yeah my best
friend that's not an option
yeah death is inevitable so i uh i had a
scooter i was probably about 12 years
old that went at least 25 to 30 miles an
hour
and i went out one time no pads no
helmet no nothing and was just booging
and then just fell and ate the worst
[ __ ] of my life they'll have the scars
on my knees to prove it on your face no
my knees oh yeah one of the worst times
i've ever eaten [ __ ] and like scrape
myself up was also on one of those i
didn't have it but a friend of mine did
and
they are very dangerous yeah when you
fall you [ __ ] fall on those things
right there's no protection yeah
hard metal just rolling around on a ball
of yeah it was brutal death well it's
probably not as bad as this
this is when you know your friends suck
dude watch this [ __ ] you look watch
closely now
oh my god yeah
i don't know why people still do this
okay wait what is this yeah i've seen
this prank before they take an air bag
and put it in someone's seat and i don't
think they understand how powerful
things are
because every time i i mean that has got
to be
not a safe activity right that's some
crazy force someone said his soul is
still sitting on the couch
it looks like one of those edits you
know oh my god they do a cut and then
they put a rag doll in yeah
um but no that's that's real
in fact
what sets it off
i think someone just push a button
so crazy yo you guys should try to find
other airbag pranks because they're all
just so so so bad roger that i mean but
this seems lethal like
could be
you hit your head hard enough i mean
yeah well also just the whiplash
exploding like that
that's a bad prank dude
he's like yeah anyway i just got off
this flight had a rough day and you know
just really nice to see you guys
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] dude friends like these huh
it's just a prank bro
yeah totally just a break energy from
that
you guys want to see the david dubrick
thing that we're got in the title that's
pretty good
sure
if you guys find more
airbags
i'd [ __ ] love to see
more okay
yeah the david dubrick thing was pretty
wild it's
it's a tick tock he posted to his own
i first saw someone reacting to it on
tick tock it's so weird that he posted
it yeah
and we're all like wow what a psycho
and then i realized wait he posted it to
his own tick tock um
i know i know maybe it'll seem like i'm
overreacting
but
i don't think i am
i think he is actually like a total
psycho
if i make this you can't see the new
spider-man movie the day it comes out oh
[Laughter]
what was the goal
i don't know
i think that i think what happened
he was trying to knock the marker out of
her hand i guess but he hit her like way
too [ __ ] hard really hard and right
in her face
is you're not seeing that [ __ ] movie
if i make this you guys what's
interesting to me is how he'd
instead of concern for her yeah he just
immediately laughs i work for free for a
week
i make this you can't see the new
spider-man movie the day it comes out
so he's like [ __ ] i'm seeing that
spider-man movie
or you're gonna die
but
he slams her in the face
i mean enough to make her bleed with a
marker so that's yeah of course
and then
and then like
a normal person will be like oh my god
i'm so sorry are you okay
yeah but his response is like
he doesn't even look at her watch this
he doesn't even look at her
it's not that serious you're [ __ ]
sick
he's such a weirdo
well also considering that he has a
history of like
injuring
uh his friends
yeah
for videos it's especially especially
interesting i don't know
am i overreacting
it's just so weird i don't know when i
first saw it i was like what why
why would you do that and it's so strong
and yes why would he post it too
it seems like he was trying to make
another one of his friends blind in one
eye
right
oh my god he's trying to rack he's
trying to rack up those eyes
there's a hunger for this character to
come back there it is and people are
looking for people want the david dobrik
who kills his friends back yeah
the good old days
yeah somebody said natalie puts up with
a lot and has a good attitude i would
have been crying i mean
i guess that's why he keeps her around
is this natalie yeah that's natalie
he's always hurting someone i just how
is this funny
out but but on the reel i mean it has
1.3 million likes i don't know what's
funny about this like what is what are
you watching here and then being like
sick tick tock bro
for free for a week you know
if i make this also can i just say that
i don't like that he did that
i don't like that he did that
i think we need to discuss that in
greater detail
i'm just baffled by to make like if
somebody's holding a pen like this right
and you want to just like you know [ __ ]
around you would hit it down you'd hit
it down or like to the side it's just
like boom you would hit it down it just
looks like he's just hitting her in the
face and not that strong
like really hard if i would hit it down
like this yeah but he did like this
he did like this
he did like this
[Laughter]
well if there's one thing
trisha left us with it is a dislike for
david dobrik
all right so
we still haven't deviated on that
i'm happy to say
okay
i don't know what that sound is you look
right it's just a funny just a funny
goofy sound
let's watch this again frame by frame
here oh
yeah here
ow like real genuine pain and then she's
like no play it off come on show your
list let's do a play but look at him
he's like angry too it's not like a
playful
you [ __ ] tick-tock
not trying to do
animals right now
i don't like that
okay so
here
first of all look how angry he gets if i
if i make this you the newness i can't
see the new spider-man nothing
spider-man movie the day it comes out oh
i remember the day it comes out comes
out
anger
he hit it right in her face
grand movie the day it comes out
whatever i don't
know right let's watch this cute dog
video what a mommy baby you're my baby
yes
[ __ ] kids
i'm [ __ ] kidding
right so he's a psycho um
that's it
look in discord
oh
what is this we got more schwartz
oh is this another airbag one could be
oh [ __ ]
just got home from work had a rough day
chilling with the homies
who i trust in love
that is so insane
that is so
or
uh better than
smacking your assistant in the face
that's that's worse do you think this
works yeah
put it in perspective here he does hit
the wall
that is worse yeah for sure
i mean it destroyed his bed by the way
too
there's one in like turkey or russia
where the guy literally just rag dolls
and like deborah gets up i mean
no it's not i'm exaggerating it's not
that bad i think i may see it here yeah
let's see that one but die i'm gonna
preview it first before i send it to you
i've seen that one like a billion times
so
um
here's some choice comments here
millionaire beats up assistant natalie
puts up with a lot obviously he didn't
learn his lesson after jeff went blind i
woke up chris breezy i don't get that
one you like that comment but i don't
understand it
isn't that chris brown
what does that mean go because he beats
women
correct i woke up chris why is it in
quotes
it's probably a reference to something
that we're not familiar with because
we're not cool we're about rumors man's
laughing nathan yep so all right chad
okay jeff
how's that funny man's laughing when he
legit smacked her in the face so there's
some sanity here
i'm not gonna read all of them though
a bonus meme in a recent interview david
threw natalie under the bus when he was
accused of not tipping oh
you think that's what happened
watch this
the other day the other day um i saw a
tick tock and it was like um someone
went to somebody's house like a
celebrity's house and they didn't tip so
i went through the comments and one of
the top comments was this gives me david
dobrik energy because like they like
apparently postmated to my house oh wait
i i saw that
and i have never in my life not tip
explain to him that tik tok and people
listening
it was like a it was like a tic tac
where um
where it was like i post mated for blah
blah blah and i went to his house and he
left me no tip like for postmates
and then all the comments were like this
gives me kesha vibes but they just kept
like listing celebrities
but people i think people were
commenting saying oh i posted it for
this person and you gave me no tip but
you didn't know what was it so it was my
name was there and i was just and i
honestly top comment i could honestly
say i've i've never ever not tipped like
from when i heard you're mister hold on
the accusation is not that you didn't
tip
is that he's a bad tipper
he's avoiding hmm
right
that's why it's so like that's why it
like those comments hurt me extra more
because it seems like i'm just being
like faking it on camera i think it
stems from there was uh a tick tock damn
if if accusations of not being a good
tipper hurts him that must imagine how
much he must feel to try to kill like
three of his friends
in separate incidents
let's feel horrible about that imagine
how the girl feels who uh
was a victim of doms
that must have really hurt his feelings
a long time ago that i saw bro it was
like this girl who like worked at a
restaurant that said david came in with
like our entire group we were all like
terrible to be around awful
it wasn't the no tip that bothered me
about that tic tac it was the girl the
girl writes on it she she uh not right
now she wrote like a note on it right
she says he didn't tip first of all he
they said i paid for the thing which i
never pay for any lunch no he doesn't i
never have he doesn't have a credit card
i don't have a credit card so it's not
possible for me to pay don't buy your
home you don't buy your homies lunch
well well then how does it there's like
the assistant has a card you know right
i'm sure it pays for it
hi yeah dick tip
we always have to he's a dick
[Laughter]
and they said that i put my card down i
left no tip and instead wrote my name
with a smiley face
i just graced you with my presence on
this thing
and like and obviously like i don't
respond to any tick tocks about myself
ever because it's just like it just
fuels attention to the thing but the the
the tick tock recently about the
doordash and not tipping the driver i
went to natalie because i was just so
pissed i was like why the [ __ ] do people
think i never tip
and natalie goes natalie goes honestly
i think that was about me
there you go what do you think
throwing her under the bus again
i don't know how i feel about that yeah
they're just joking around maybe this
one's reaching
but
what do you think am i reaching a little
bit
the story that he as he described it of
that tick tock it did sound like
[ __ ]
that he that he wrote a smiley face with
his name yeah no but the door there was
a door dasher who says he didn't tip and
then he's then natalie he basically yeah
i mean his story has a giant hole in it
where he's like i always tip i always
tip and then like 30 seconds later he's
like i don't have a card i never pay
it's like exactly
yeah
it was definitely a little sus little
you know a little see and and also you
really don't have a card you're a grown
ass man you've been here for how long
you're a business owner you need a
credit card you need credit you need
credit to buy a house he bought a house
the [ __ ] david liar
yeah it's odd i'm sure his business has
cards yeah but he doesn't carry one if
you buy a house
yeah what he means is i don't carry one
because i don't like to buy people [ __ ]
that's what he means he likes to be like
i don't have
dude that's exactly he's a cheapo he uh
this all adds up i just unlocked the
whole pandora's box he doesn't hold the
only people that don't carry cards with
them are cheapos who don't want to buy
[ __ ]
he's rich everyone expects him to pay
for everything he doesn't want to pay so
he doesn't bring a car doesn't have
cashes i have no way to pay
i don't know about that i'm telling you
what adds up
um
i think he just thinks it's cute
to be the
you can never pay anyone back no to be
like the
the child that um
he just shows up and then everybody does
everything
right
that's interesting too
that's interesting
[Laughter]
oh here's the one i was looking for
uh yeah this is oh wait no this is a
different one god people keep doing this
oh my gosh
look at it oh okay i like that we got
the slow-mo
watch his neck
on the slow-mo
boom
see you later
and
it's not like you ever saw one of these
and said hey this is a good idea because
they all look horrible yeah look at this
look at his [ __ ] neck dude oh my god
just that's that's gotta hurt your
testicles so bad oh interesting i didn't
even think about that level of impact i
mean pushing them up
out of your mouth type [ __ ] like
that's gotta [ __ ] hurt dude
damn
it's
maybe you know if you're
this is instead of getting a uh
vasectomy
right you just sit on the airbags you
can smash your plastic your nuts into
oblivion oh yeah you ain't have a kid
i got medicine yeah no way
they are just probably medicine that's
all right guys
all right it's really screaming okay so
how does this work
you want to look me up um
now that you brought it i'm getting so
much itchier
okay
okay guys here we go drink cream up
kind of cream up drug the facts tell me
about the drug facts rectal bleeding
occurs i'm not even kidding
why does it say rectal bleeding occurs
it just says wait you got to show that
it just says rectal bleeding occurs
it just says that
what does it say directly it's a
guarantee oh okay well that's the price
you pay no it says continue
there's gotta be more info yeah where's
the rest it just says drunk facts rectal
bleeding occurs
it's the blood of god
hold on where is this continued from
before i start lubing this all over my
face
it says
what the [ __ ] is that that's some
[ __ ] to put it like that
wait we gotta show a close-up of that
then can you guys do a close-up somehow
it's really small
of the the box yeah
i don't think with this camera
we'll have to do another it's gonna be
yeah
oh i just received a message from olivia
that that cheers have started to uh all
right let's go populate through i'll
send you guys a picture and then you can
show the picture
oh yeah that's good
breaking news
we have
cheers in the audience i'm getting them
uh i'm getting them reconnected
it'll be a minute
all right well i'm busy so
it looks
disgusting yeah i know
i feel like a freak somehow just
strong that makes you look like you're
you have like uh mutton shops right now
oh it's right here you look like a civil
war general
right i really do what the [ __ ]
it's actually not itchy here and here
it's just on the this part it's on the
cheeks yeah just on the juice plot those
cheeks
can you guys send this in discord
yeah you yeah pull that up yeah this is
what's going to be happening a little
bit later
you're going to be with theodore tonight
because
i'm going to have what is guaranteed to
be rectal bleeding
wait it looks like that
well i guess maybe i don't want to ruin
the joke
i think i have an explanation i want the
explanation look at the bottom left oh
this is a continuation of this i know
but it's so funny just show the picture
god damn it all right i got you jesus
yeah i get what you're saying it says on
the other side stop use and ask doctor
if
and then i guess this is one of the
points how would that happen for me
putting it on my face
i guess my rectum starts bleeding from
face cream that's a problem that would
be a huge problem
i feel like don't even make it if that's
a possible outcome don't even sell this
to me because there's only two points
one is suicidal thoughts you see a
doctor
one is condition worsens symptoms
persist for more than seven days and
then the other one is erectile bleeding
on
cbs are you gonna sell me this [ __ ] all
right i think um i think we have
mr ayad with us
out on the field
all right can you hear us
yes can you hear me your camera's
flipped bro
your shit's flipped you guys are
crushing my [ __ ]
olivia can you flip it
hey
there you go what's going on okay
guys uh it seems britney is free
britney really
[Music]
and we were there let's get a pulse
tell me about the
the mood there tell me about the
excitement what's happening up there
there's a lot of movement in front of
our camera we're trying to record that's
okay but uh yeah everyone's super
excited wow
what looks like today
is signing something this gentleman is
very excited okay that's great
good for him how's it going i am so
excited i'm so happy
yeah behind my glasses i've never been
this excited about anything
my boyfriend
he's a huge part of this too
but i'm so excited for her i've been
waiting for 13 years for this
conservative ship to end i lost my first
tooth in 1999 at the baby one more time
tour and now here i am i feel like i've
got bolstered whipping me seeing her
grow as a person she helped me grow as a
gay man she's obviously the icon
i just cannot be happier for her
[Applause]
but please do not forget about everyone
else stealing their contributorship they
still need our help and advocacy
right
thank you thank you
thank you bro wow wow wow wow wow what
an exciting exciting time what a thrill
and and i must say as a uh jamie spears
fan a disappointing day for me
a sad day for very saturday
trisha being one of them i remember she
was sipping for jamie right so she's got
to be better yeah keep restoring you
still hear me restore the
conservatorship
look look at these mainstream
do me a favor a b ask the reporter what
her thoughts are
[Laughter]
he's waiting patiently uh he's a go in
there
can i ask you what your thoughts are
[Laughter]
olivia trade with olivia
will do it there you go olivia ask the
cameraman what his thoughts are
how do you feel
there's a pink sign behind you
what are you doing what it what are they
doing
she can't hear me anymore
do you want to be interviewed
how do you feel how you doing about
ready to be free absolutely so much
corruption has gone on especially in
ventura county they need to be held
accountable criminal
criminal accountable would be
paid that victims need to be paid
reparations for the damage they've done
rooting families for their own great
ill-gotten gain with uh sociopathic
people who are just taking money for
their own good just like that done with
brittany
i totally agree we're not really talking
about breaking i think he's talking
about a different situation
can you ask him olivia um
can you ask that man has he been wronged
by someone in his own family and that's
why he relates
he's on the go
sorry i have a follow-up question yes
yes the host of the show is asking have
you been wrong by someone in your family
yes oh not by my family no by the
professional conservator angelique's
friend who was robbed in our family my
mother just recently passed ashley
friend did not did not notify us for
over three days when he got accidentally
found out by some other source that as
she's robbed our family
david escapist her attorney
has taken advantage of us hundreds of
thousands of dollars and put us in
bankruptcy it's devastating it's wrong
and it needs to be ended maybe yeah
famous university
as in to who's with them need to be held
accountable for their wrongdoing
i think is there
if there's any way we can get the free
brittany guys the whole crowd there
maybe we could get them all to go over
to ventura
to petition on his behalf would you like
that
so the host of the show is asking is
there any way we can get all the bricks
to form some kind of uh yes yes right
here right here right here right here
what does that mean
oh he's he's got
um servicemen mine in korean
laces in world war ii
they were
in ventura county they were not allowed
to be home with us for registered nurses
and they died my dad died alone in
february i was notified by email that he
was dead and he was not allowed to play
with me plus they took all of his assets
it is disgusting what the courts
and conservators are doing in this state
it needs to stop now
so this a w for britney is a w for
everyone
okay thank you guys so much thank you
thank you thank you wow there's a lot of
seriousness
a lot of serious uh stuff going on there
yeah abs being held aside by this
gentleman
amy
amy
okay olivia can you give us a panorama
view i want to kind of just see what's
going on around there
god this video is really something
yeah
if there's any other reporters i'd like
to talk to them
i enjoyed that
maybe you guys can find some other
reporters
uh we'll look for around
all right check back in
thank you so much
oh what's
this what does he want
uh he said he's gonna sue you next ethan
okay come on okay got it i'm unsc i'm
unafraid
where we're reporting from um ask this
guy in the shirt
i want to ask the people who don't care
at all
basically who have no opinion
would you be interested in an interview
okay go ahead
so are you here for brittany yes we're
here for britney spears and uh that's
what they can use the megaphone please
and how
how they're run
trafficking the violation of due process
constitutional rights trial by jury no
oversight accountable to nobody
just to continue what he was saying with
the megaphone
[Laughter]
agendas um
[Laughter]
thank you
[Laughter]
thanksgiving plans what's the answer
with the megaphone can i just olivia can
you show them that
he has not stopped now he's the whole
rest of the crowd well go back to him i
want to talk to him
but everybody has to answer on the
megaphone okay we have
follow-up questions we're on our live
broadcast sir
do you have any thanksgiving plans
what's the megaphone with the megaphone
we do it all online whatever
he said can you use the
megaphone thanksgiving plans is to to to
remember the children that cannot be
with family they're being trafficked oh
no turkey there that was slick no turkey
then right back
we have an
estimated 000 missing foster kids that
nobody's looking for and 99 of them are
not on their mission exploited children
doubt about wait is this real what are
you talking about because this is
concerning me nobody is accountable
to kybash on this
the website is
mylocator.com as well as cts
newsnetwork.com we'll cover it all we're
on cps news network on facebook okay we
got it and then is he gonna be having
turkey or no
thanksgiving plans man
is he gonna have turkey
if there's no crime you cannot take
children
yeah so turkey or
so
uh turkey or cranberry sauce what's
going on
yeah it's gonna be uh uh mashed potatoes
and corn
yeah oh yeah all right
all right thank you so much
let's actually pull up that website you
said my locator.com wait
maybe chad chad did you guys uh
did i miss here that url mylocator.com
did anyone get the address of that
website
there's a lot of people who are very mad
at us for uh laughing at this by the way
just just a heads up what did i do
i didn't do anything i'm gonna go to i'm
not mad i'm bringing i'm bringing
attention
what are they mad about oh who knows
what are we like they're always mad
about the missing kids or about brittany
for laughing at this i think that
there's there's these are serious issues
and when we're laughing
we're just laughing here on a comedy
show could you imagine
oh what's this this is interesting i
cannot hear what the hell is saying wow
[Music]
this is awesome
we can't get the audio but
it's great
this man's here for brittany
[Music]
he's actually not he's here to bring uh
awareness to the issue of the homeless
encampments at macarthur park
by the way
santa barbara county first of all if
you're angry at me
i can't hear first of all and i don't
know if there's like conspiracy theories
going on about like you know pizzagate
stuff or if this is real issues i'm
investigating it now i'm trying to give
it its due
attention but i don't know what's going
on down there i know you guys are gonna
like this it's just chaos and so i'm not
out of breath he's out of breath turn
off the mic on this one
amy give him the phone
i hope you guys like give them the phone
tell them there's fifty thousand people
tell them there's forty thousand people
watching go up on stage dude
there's forty thousand people watching
okay you wanna hand it to him we have
fifty thousand live viewers 50 000 live
viewers
nobody's come on dude
oh [ __ ] they're about to go oh [ __ ]
let's go right now
brittany's free baby let's go i want to
see a b i need the camera to tilt down i
need to see a b right now okay
you're grooving out
all right we can't play this music
actually oh yeah all right thank you
amy did we get us the website though so
we can look into it so people don't get
mad at me
we can actually bring attention to these
very serious issues with peace and love
thank you
yeah because mylocator.com is about a
group of entrepreneurs with extensive
experience in name branding and digital
real estate exactly he's just trying to
promote his real estate project
maybe i love the guy from venezuela
we're from ventura the dude from santa
barbara
um
here's the story britney spears
conservatorship terminated brittany is
hey
go queen
she's a free woman the judge has swiftly
ended her conservatorship effective
immediately
get [ __ ] jamie spears and all those
other pieces of [ __ ]
the judge terminated the conservatorship
without requiring any further mental
evaluation
something brittany was adamant about the
hearing started
with britney's lawyer matt uh rosengart
quoting britney's june testimony in
which she said i just want my life back
amen
yeah this is crap this is wild that this
went on for so long yeah and it's nice
to know that this one judge was like
this is [ __ ]
we're just gonna end this now you know
she was able to hire her own attorney
and then things just started happening
from there it's such a travesty it's
just such a disgusting corrupt
freak show what happened to her
rosengart her lawyer believes there has
been misappropriation of assets by
various people on the conservatorship at
the expense of brittany as we reported
her state is worth an estimated 60
million i know that's a lot of money but
i feel like she should be worth way more
than definitely britney spears
she should definitely be women like
hundreds you would guess
i forgot
as rosengart believes it should be much
larger uh but would be for
lawyers jamie
lao taylor and others taking cuts and
salaries from the estate yeah
exactly
bro you could have just asked her for
money you didn't have to do all this
brittany wants to get back in the studio
and record music
interesting
uh this is me as a
uh uh
is that grant or something ulysses some
sort of union general i'm not sure it's
it's general ethan klein
fighting for freedom looks good
the year was 1979
1879
[Music]
all was quiet
because the war had ended 15 years prior
[Music]
1860
1859.
wait someone said it's hemorrhoid cream
i put on my face
no well why would everybody else want to
talk about her anal why ladies rectal
why would it prevent that dude has been
spamming that all
right
let me read it says maximum strength
itch bro i swear to god this is [ __ ]
hemorrhoid cream i just slathered on my
face okay let me read the directions
for itching or skin irritation
inflammation or rashes
vitamin e and aloe
no it's not it's not a hemorrhoid cream
and this is for external use
adults and children two years of age
apply to affected area
for external
oh [ __ ] for external anal and genital
itching
wait really cancer
no i swear to god it says that well it
says that 1.48
it says here for itching or skin
inflammation and then it also says
for external anal and genital itching
wait are there commas between those
things yes okay then you're good that
means it's it's okay to put it it's yes
gentlemen for external comments it's for
it says it's for irritation even from
jewelry so
yeah cosmetics soaps there you go okay
sorry for doubting you elena
do you see the flame coming out of td
jake's butt
it's still issue guys it's not we'll put
more i put like half slather it on i
feel like a stick of chapstick
[Music]
do you have to be directly applying put
it in your hand like a big blob and then
no i rubbed it in
see
what a mess
wait guys we can't find the website he
was plugging so people like likely i
think
let's give attention
i'm curious listen he's saying there's
ten thousand missing orphans i mean this
is urgent
foster children
um okay dan split hairs missing kids
listen people keep sending me the urls
that they thought it was none of them
work it probably got the hug of death
from everybody going to it so there you
go you see we're bringing awareness when
you guys are giving me [ __ ]
i'm saving the orphans
i'm a [ __ ] saint
how dare you
you guys got to admit that chaotic
it's just chaos it was funny
oh here we go who's this this is just
olivia
ask olivia's thoughts ab
he's missing a lens on his glasses what
happened
oh they're muted
can't hear you guys
all right fantastic
yeah yeah go ahead
yeah uh look at this point
baby we can't hear anything
no baby
you may also hear a little bit when we
hear olivia it's connected to her ear
buds or whatever it's connected to my
yeah for sure
look at me i look cute
what i was saying was i had no idea that
i was missing the
and olivia just told me i don't know how
long i've been walking with things
it was like that the whole time
i had no clue and these are very
expensive
bombers apparently not that expensive
falling out yeah yeah so
we're taking a lunch break all right
enjoy good job guys
take care out there enjoy your lunch you
guys are crushing crushing it
wow
well she's free my friends
what's up okay
so streaming in public was a mistake
hands are just covered in chapstick and
anal cream attention
in the back this is for you
bald white man
bald white man
bald white man
bald white man
would have people donate and it would
make they could choose what to say
so it's like base people into donating
you to embarrass you gotcha but they
used to do what happened was there was
like super racist [ __ ] and i don't know
hold on here's a b's glasses earlier in
the episode
this [ __ ] was cruising with one
lens the whole time no they look intact
here yeah they're intact there
oh interesting what happened
he lost a lens in the chaos
evie did that everyone saw that
all right i gotta go like clean up
because i'm feeling not great
[Music]
um just roll with it is it not helping
the itching
it's hard to say i just feel like a
disgusting freak though right now it's
benadryl ointment right or what does it
say on the bottom
here it says here the active ingredients
hydrocortisine
yeah
yeah that's good yeah that's the good
[ __ ] i'd leave it on
good [ __ ] dude
that's good [ __ ] bro i huff that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up is that good
um
oh we have some good cav cab updates
hilo
um they're really good i know you don't
necessarily care about this stuff
but i'm telling you they're really good
so cav cav has recently
maybe can you link me to his instagram
and check for myself but he's started to
pay bots to leave comments about me
under his page now
allegedly
right allegedly
i mean who else
yeah so someone said bro that's funny
you're the biggest bully of them all
he's still responding to people in the
comments this is the guy who's suing me
by the way
uh erroneously trying to bankrupt me out
of spite he is a terrible dude a
disgusting freak and
he is using the law
as a tool for revenge and uh i'm
fighting back that's right cavanaugh ceo
of triller
you may ask what is trailer well nobody
knows nobody uses it
bro that's funny you're one of the
biggest bullies uh why do you have zero
followers and zero people
you're following ethan klein maybe yeah
he always thinks that anytime you get to
meet common it's me
yeah
such matt hossbot it's so weird
why is ik so so here he starts getting
these comments why is ek so fixated on
you it's so desperate even his own fans
are turning on him i mean he gave the he
gave the game away this is what he's
doing
his own fans are turning on him
and he has i think he has ethan klein
blocked
oh
whoa
[Applause]
no way
so he's hiring people to
allegedly to circumvent his own block on
my name
look at your dm's i sent you info on ek
and his shady stuff
why is he watching stuff wait here's the
exact same comment
how is this possible ryan that this
account left the same exact comment as
this different account why is ek so
fixated on you it's desperate even his
own fans are turning on him that's uh
familiar huh
that's weird
ek desperation coming through and you
keep taking the high road yeah like he's
got all these fans it's wrong the ek
thing is so weird like no one ever
refers to you like that
hunger
the
foreign
the this
i never encountered anything like this
this man is hiring bots allegedly
to defend him
and then say that you are doing that
but also to circumvent the block he has
on my name that's amazing
let's see how many of ek purchase
account comment here should be obvious
on this one
oh and then he started misspelling my
name
dm i have stuff on ethan that can bury
him yeah i'm sure
what the [ __ ] dude this is so crazy this
is like so freaky and then this guy's
saying can't wait to see ethan get
buried like they're all
using the same language
and also misspelling my name in the same
way like literally nobody ever spell it
that way even in the worst misspellings
nobody spelled that way ek sports in the
game
e-e
here it is again ethan has so much
baggage he's about to go down he should
learn this words
is he trying to actually scare me
yeah i don't know is he trying to make
me think that there's actually like
people in ryan's comments
trying to take me down probably well
they say they have the dirt on you so
maybe you should be able to again ryan
continues to underestimate me he doesn't
know the forces i've been against i mean
i've been at war with keemstar for like
five years right exactly and what i mean
oh no he's gonna he's gonna tell him
about the jimmy lee did you hear that he
was the dick to jimmy lee
i'm a good boy ryan gonna be buried i'm
gonna bury you wait hey if you think
what i've done is bad you should see
what ryan's done actually i have a
website that outlines it
does ryan
oh [ __ ]
by the way how's that one raiding so far
does ryan
kavanagh look like harvey weinstein
oh it's at the top that can't be real
here let's go incognito guys and feel
free to everyone type this because this
is important love you want to explain
yeah well you search after the sky if
you search the whole thing of course you
can beat that does ryan
kavanagh
look um it's hard on the
look like harvey weinstein so you want
to explain the significance of typing it
like this
yeah yeah you know every time someone
searches anything in google
that is going to give google signals for
that website to come higher up in the
search oh wait type rank have it on not
not yeah that's my i was a bit confused
yeah there
so
i think paul
yes
so you want to type ryan cavanaugh in
and then you want to scroll down and
find the website yeah that way
that way um
you don't looks like we've slipped on a
bit
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
he pays for like seo manipulation we
found that out the other week well
allegedly yeah so he's led by somebody
that did it for him
you know be crazy if we paid people to
do that that would be crazy
[Laughter]
yeah so if you guys think that being
addicted it's number three on duckduckgo
interesting oh so that so that would
imply that he is or let's not say he but
there is some manipulation of somebody
out there is manipulating his seo where
what they could just be an interested
third party who's just a big ryan
cavanaugh fan doing it for him yeah
everything we're high up
one of these oh on bing we're high up
too eh oh yeah boy i just i just uh
duck duck goat it and it's uh the number
two for me no way
[Laughter]
his personal website we're above his
personal website here
okay so if you go to bing this is this
is [ __ ] yeah so duck.go is basically
like the true their whole thing is like
no manipulation
right this is all true theoretically
yeah yeah so
so this is basically without people
paying them to spend time on the website
to make it more relevant this is what it
looks like on being obviously there's
less manipulation going on we type ryan
cavanaugh
he's gonna be
let's see here
number four yeah would you look at that
yeah
that's pretty good okay i'm impressed
guys definitely something fishy with
going on google absolutely fishy
yeah if you go ahead and scroll uh at
the bottom of the website we've added
something new very new and very
exclusive
at the bottom there test yourself
test yourself with the ryan cavanaugh
game oh yes sir oh so oh this is
officially up guys the ryan cavanaugh
game
your skills
so guys we've added a ryan cavanaugh
game as you know the public
is confused
and we've made this as a public service
honestly to benefit ryan kavanagh
because he wants to be mistaken
for harvey weinstein even a guy as
shitty as ryan he's worse than ryan
so calling out all
musicians
top left if you want
okay i'm ready i mean it's part of the
experience yeah okay here we go maybe
you guys can help me at home
is that ryan or harvey somewhere there
between i'm gonna say that that's ryan
ah
it's so hard harvey harvey harvey harvey
[ __ ] that was right no yeah so the
longer you take the less the more points
you lose so the faster so is that ryan
or harvey i'm going to say harvey yes oh
okay
we are learning we're getting better
[ __ ]
i think that's
right okay good yeah look at you i'm
getting better at this down the street
yeah we've got all of our favorite tunes
oh this is a tough one this challenge
that's for sure ryan
i don't know
it's coming there's like a hand here
oh yeah that's right that's right that's
ryan
what yeah well anyway it is it's really
hot hard so it's fun i guess if you like
heart difficult games it's like dark
souls in that way yeah you know i do
want to give a shout out to or this is
my personal shout out because i know
ethan doesn't do shadows anymore so
blue pin studio is the guy he's the guy
has he made any anti-semitic comments
about me possibly love that
no i don't believe so but you know
anyways he's linked right below
that game
there's nothing on love
is ryan responsible for this
no i think so
what what is their name i'll get i do
want to shout them out they help make
this game yeah so the link is below the
thing it's uh they're called blue pin
studio i just think it's one guy really
lupin is super cool
and he has a steam game coming out and
he's doing all kind of fun stuff indie
gamer indie game developer very cool
lupin studio we love you we appreciate
you
yeah and i'm sorry that ryan is going to
be adding you to the next complaint but
you know what you're getting yourself
into
ryan's like looped in studio
yeah yeah so guys head on over to does
ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein remember to type in ryan cavin
on the search and go ahead and try your
your skills at the game on the bottom
there
oh blue pin studio i'm sorry blue pin
studio i need to take more quizzes
because i just i suck at this data yeah
go home and spend some time on the
website that's the whole idea right i'm
definitely gonna do that like the more
times people people spend on the website
you know the more google is gonna like
it right right
it's a bit broken on mobile but we'll
fix that at some point and i was really
i was enjoying reading these hate
comments to continue can't wait to see
ethan get k get buried ethan has so much
baggage he's about to go down he should
learn this words
with the guy with the uh
was that the
the anon uh
oh and also guys by the way just so you
know it's real love triller
thriller
can you imagine a more pathetic human
being that would actually like pay for
this to happen this is some sad
sad [ __ ] bizarre
what a sad dude
this guy really thinks he's he's doing
something
let's go to some here metallica's going
live oh man i'm not logged in
or maybe this is it maybe just don't
show for now
okay i'm gonna login so i can read the
comments
how's your face
it feels better
does it still look super gross
it seems to be getting redder and more
swollen since you put the cream on are
you serious
a little bit do you see that is my face
getting red and more swollen do you feel
any moisture in your [ __ ]
i feel good
my i think my [ __ ] is bleeding
like doesn't it look what is happening
you know
you're supposed to spot to check stuff
that you put on your face like it's not
exactly
yeah like put on a small spot
oh really
yeah
well i didn't do that
i just squirted it all over that's what
the chat is saying they're saying you
look puffy no way i'm puffier is it not
just my hair what you're saying right
next to me
it looks maybe the same but i'm not sure
i know that they're saying it lift your
head up like tilt your head up to see
under
okay see how like red it is like right
where
i think you need benadryl pills
yeah i need a shot yeah you need more
stuff
more ass bleeding baby
here can you put this on my ass crack
it doesn't itch i just want to get ahead
of it
you probably should go wash your face
okay
yeah yeah can you log into instagram
while i do that uh yeah
log into instagram i can oh and there
um
oh man oh okay one second
the dan and elo podcast all right
we got a donation towards a new love bot
so what's happening is it actually
broken like i think well the charger has
this issue where this little uh cable
inside got snipped
and so i
did surgery on it and i spliced the
cable but
sometimes when
he violently starts rocking like he was
earlier in the episode it knocks it
loose again and that appears to have
happened now so it's no longer charging
if you did that everyone saw that yeah
it all
it all started going downhill once baby
kicked him i got us yeah he [ __ ] that
that was the beginning of the end it's
fine i forget forgiven maybe yeah oh for
the record that's sweet
that's very sweet of you you don't have
to say that you shouldn't say that
you shouldn't forgive i did
that's what i believe okay ela how is
your day going so far
um
good thank you
and
yeah all good just getting we're both
kind of starting to get a little anxious
because it's um
three months still till the baby yeah
oh my gosh excited we're gonna be here
before we know it
and we're a little scared
but
everybody says second time
should be a little easier
because you kind of know better what
you're doing
right how is house theodore is he
excited theodore has actually been doing
really good this week
he's been pooping on the potty hey
yeah let's go
so
that's been awesome
okay
instagram is logged in the first thing
that popped up is i guess
big ed is uh
engaged oh no way he is yeah it's
official
okay so shout out big man everybody
really turns out that guy seems like
everybody [ __ ] hates him now honestly
it was hard to watch i guess he had
there's a new season of some show
coming out or something something i
don't know
oh
so it might not even be real no no i i
think he's actually engaged okay yeah
all right
i think we're good
um
yeah so
good week with theodore finally i'm good
yeah
i thought it would never happen
um
what else
the teddy fresh pop-up tomorrow that's
that's super exciting
yeah
um
i'm i think i've been not sleeping well
all week just because i'm
hoping everything goes okay
[Music]
but i'm excited yeah just
just don't know what to expect like
what kind of uh
last minute somebody donated five bucks
and said eli needs a runway to show her
fit at the top of the show
you should build like a little
fashion corner somewhere
so we can kick off the show like that
um
a nurse said uh dan hydrocortisone is a
strong steroid wash it off light layer
only oral antihistamine seed doctor if
system if symptoms persist
from a nurse thank you mackenzie
yeah
yeah i was definitely noticing
some there's some reaction going on
there swelling up all right you okay
then
apparently apparently you kind of [ __ ]
up putting a bunch of that all over your
face is uh
well a nurse sent a uh a super chat and
said um
yeah um that it's like cortisone is a
strong steroid you should really only
use a light amount so well what the [ __ ]
what does it have a warning about using
it
yeah look at my i've got a [ __ ] i got
a brush on my
do you see a rash forming on my forehead
a little maybe ethan can i
yeah
i just want to see we'll come up a
little bit yeah
you can't see it from there no wait oh
you go to him yeah yeah you can't
hear
i mean it's fun for the show it's kind
of exciting um you see a rash on my
forehead like right here there's bubbles
for me
well yeah there's like a rash
huh yeah you don't see it yeah
what's going on with you
i'm
my face is coming up i wonder if i
should shave the beard off live
so we can see what's going on underneath
there
do we have wait every time i still have
that uh that trimmer that we got the
really nice one
i think it's here yeah bring it over
huh okay so i [ __ ] up i i rubbed
steroids all over my face
what are you talking about oh wait
leftovers hasn't come out yet
there's a long conversation about
steroids in leftovers this weekend um so
i thought maybe you were uh this isn't
yeah misunderstanding steroids
that's right
uh ouch apparently people are spamming
james charles dating profile
i don't know what that means
that sounds like something i would love
to see yeah it hurts it itches it's
inflamed it's horrible oh my god
and my eye now my eyelids are itching oh
no
don't touch
it's not poison ivy
just i don't know so yeah something's
going on i think you need to take
benadryl pill like in all seriousness
who's got a benadryl pill
i tried to what
yes you know someone is saying uh that
shaving it would only irritate it more
and i kind of agree like isn't shaving
irritating for the skin well not with a
razor with a yeah i can i okay i just
figure
if i remove it i can actually treat the
skin
are you in a lot of pain
i wouldn't say a lot it's very
discomforting though
ben and jerusi well i got benadrucy
well here i got i got aloe
and i got vaseline vaseline couldn't
hurt right blue about my whole [ __ ]
face i i don't
i don't know maybe just don't touch it i
would it's irritated i don't know
vaseline helps everything
right
did you check your sphincter when you
were in the bathroom i haven't i didn't
i didn't check my ass okay
just checking yeah
and we're going into the weekend like
you won't be able to see a doctor
probably
well i could go to urgent care if i need
to i don't think i'll need to
i don't care about my face
always happen on the weekend
i just every time i try to grow a beard
i says you know what i'm going to grow a
beard i'm going to make this happen i'm
going to commit i've been doing good
i've been trying to maintain it i've
been brushing it and stuff yeah and now
my face is melting off under my [ __ ]
beard no i just don't understand why is
god do this to me
well just be thankful for being the
hairline king
right i'll always have the hairline king
you can't beat the beard king and
they're liking trust me i'm not the beer
king i just want to grow a beard my
beard is a nightmare
i think it's fine the way you keep it
like shorter
i like it like that
you do you don't like this no
you didn't like the way i cut it like
this either because it makes me look i
mean it just looks a little
cut too short or something yeah
it'll all be good man
my face is starting to get more itchy
what are you trying to call in first aid
9-1-1
oh [ __ ]
probably for the best i don't think you
should do this
all right let's just move let's just
carry on what is the james charles
dating thing everyone spamming
let me try and find out but me in the
meantime let's look at ryan having those
comments because that that really does
amuse me
it's got to be
dude is not stripping yeah he's he's not
a stable human being just drop the
lawsuit then what do you want
well
i'm happy to fight the lawsuit but he
didn't have to get fake comments about
me on his [ __ ] instagram allegedly
i'm just saying he's he's acting like
we are the ones doing it to him it's
like drop the lawsuit he's doing a spite
lawsuit trying to ruin our lives and god
forbid i actually fight back against a
[ __ ] total fraudulent copyright
lawsuit well [ __ ] you bro and let's not
forget the dm he sent me saying i don't
know you're playing with
seriously settled too yeah i made him a
reasonable settlement offer
i offered him like 25 000. i said look i
don't want to do another lawsuit there's
25 000
for you to [ __ ] off and by the way so
much more
than
yeah i made good faith attempt more than
i ever gave matt haas to just say you
know what just [ __ ] off and leave me
alone
he said no i need a hundred thousand
dollars first he was like a million a
million i was like yeah
he's and then his lawyer was like listen
what he really wants is a hundred
thousand i said just you know what are
you sure didn't they want more than that
i remember well his lawyer was like i
think if you offer a hundred thousand
he'll take it i said i'm not giving that
[ __ ] a hundred thousand dollars no
[ __ ] way i'm giving him even 25 000
makes me want to
slam my head against the concrete
but okay i'm not more than happy to
bring back up the mantle of copyright
i mean
take this l my friend
because i earned you so much goodwill
the first time
yeah exactly
that's a really good point dan
people are getting stressed from
watching you
they're saying my face is getting bigger
it's exciting
oh my god my face looks so blocky and
[ __ ] up
yeah if you i don't know if you can see
but on the edges here there's
a
yeah violet you're turning violet violet
yeah exactly
oh somebody suggested since we can't um
shave it because the clipper's not here
maybe we could wax it like that guy the
other day oh my god
absolutely never
they're saying stress hives it's not
stress
it's gotta be an allergy
an allergic response
oh it is back oh you're back i didn't
even think about it
yeah you want let's do a little debris
for uh ab here he just walked back in
um i'm just trying to find
does anything look weird to you maybe
come get a close look at me
you have no con you have no context of
what's going on
just get a close look at my
what's happening did you get sunburned
anything
he said did you get sunburned do you see
anything else take a closer look he
hasn't left the house and be brutally
honest
no i just see redness right here that's
it that's it
why
what am i missing his redness he may
have rubbed a bunch of steroid cream all
over his face earlier and now he's
having a reaction do you feel stronger
no
no i don't
all right saying wash your face you did
i just did i just rinsed it all off yeah
all right whatever [ __ ] you ryan wait
maybe this isn't a bad one because he
was telling people to comment it takes
grace to remain kind and cruel
situations shut up
freak
it takes grace to add a bunch of
lawsuits every week to sue me twice
once for defamation for saying you look
like harvey weinstein
what great cruel situations that you are
the person initiating
and can end at any time
oh my god here's this is the classic
fake comment the best of the best
best of the best two flames baby how
much you want to bet it's private
oh it's not private wait whoa
wait hold on maybe this is it
is this a real person
saying best of the best maybe they're
just improving their uh
some profiles a little bit
and then he's got a link to another one
because we
it's strange there's do you think
there's a real person saying the best of
the best the best of the best is one of
those phrases that we kept seeing come
on that's what i'm saying but i clicked
it this time and it took me to this
homie
huh
best of the best
maybe he really is the best of the best
he's the best
like no it has no relation to anything
just best of the best with 10 likes
maybe he's trying to get a trailer deal
or some [ __ ]
yo triller
truly the best of the best
oh maybe it's because
maybe these are our fans goofing on him
oh
that makes it because you guys already
talked about it oh
of course because this one says uh
truly best of the best cabbie boy yeah
yeah that's totally our fans
when is the next
queef contest being held
someone asked
yeah
yeah i love this man he is the biggest
piece of [ __ ] in the game what the [ __ ]
is this post weirdo
the icl nerf family
uh okay this is like a holocaust meme or
he's talking about i think that's his
family oh it is
as real as it gets my great my
grandparents great grandparents great
uncles and aunts and uncles and aunts
we'll never forget they fought to live
so that we could have a future okay
shout out to the
eichner family
do you think ryan's related to billy
eichner
who's that
the comedian
billy on the street yeah that guy oh no
no relation for sure
anyway shout out shout outs
did you find any intel on that james
charles thing uh it seems to be a story
from like a month ago is all that was
really popping up about i think we even
talked about on the show maybe i don't
see that many people bringing it up
dating dating profile
where he was on straight tinder
oh yeah that happens all the time yeah
like every few months can you believe
he's still doing that though he has a
tinder
profile a as a woman
yeah i think we talked about it
such a psycho
dude is so [ __ ] in the head
let's get glam also there's an
astroworld update apparently
yeah that well so
a tragically horribly
a ninth person
did they perish or they were pronounced
like brain dead which basically
you know they were uh they were brain
dead yeah
welcome back by the way guys thank you
how was the experience
i was really nice very kind people
i'd agree yeah
good vibes besides breaking my glasses
but besides that did you find out what
happened to your glasses yeah so i found
the pieces it must have fell at some
point and huh i just didn't notice the
end i don't know how yo who drew that
picture of love that's really good uh
that would be cam grant's oh that makes
sense wow yeah
i was like damn someone really
did that together yeah cam's a talent
okay well welcome back guys good work
thank you
yes so um
apparently they were instructed at the
staff at astro
world
if people died i don't know why they
were planning for that but to call them
smurfs and not
to what kind of
refer to them as dead but smurfs what
kind of sicko
is that like normal event planning to
prevent canceling or like uh
panic yeah that's what i was going to
suggest it's just like a code name
smartphone we got smurfs everywhere can
you imagine a little weird there is
everywhere we got nine smurfs
maybe you should just say it because
apparently nobody figured it out
a little panic would have been nice
maybe in that situation more than what
was
i'm itching my arms are itchy and my
legs are itchy
and uh drill ben adrian give me benadryl
what can i do who just has benadryl well
we need to get some uh
well we might this is right now you
might need to lean
thank you
this backfired
wait what did i miss what happened we
are not sure it looks like he has some
kind of an allergy reaction
maybe
dying eyelid cheek beard we need a bus
and also genitals crotch rocks i'm sorry
this is so weird
i'm sorry soap or something yeah it
might have been a soap thing either
thing but quartering sends his regards
um
oh i this was a great video i saw so
this is um
once again [ __ ] the police i'm sorry i'm
just gonna come out and say it like
straight wow
i know bravery
hey by the way just like that on a
friday
on live on air
yo pull up that picture of the bit the
pig with giant balls
okay that i sent in the what's that it
really cracked me up we're really
jumping around here for one thing no
[Laughter]
this is me when i say [ __ ] the police
this is how i feel go ahead dan hold on
did you see anyone
[Laughter]
i was very confused
what were you confused about
i mean it's funny but why
why not
i dropped this in the
podcast chat at 4am last night
i was having lunch when you sent things
yes this is how i feel saying [ __ ] the
police that's the point
those those are like bigger than his
stomach like look at the comparisons
oh an amazing companion to my favorite
image of all time
yeah yo pigs are jealous god
is not okay disgusting bro
it's not okay what about these balls
they're like swollen or
something just because i don't think
there's i don't think your balls are
supposed to catch your [ __ ]
you can if you could get that off the
screen i'd appreciate it
okay i don't think needs something
no
please i i
what's the difference
why this one is way easier to look at
yeah this one's way easier to look guys
you don't want to see a giant piece of
[ __ ] sitting on his
this one's just nature baby
but this guy if he takes a dump it's
just maybe it will nick his balls but
it's not gonna rest there
it's gonna slide over it
yeah so anyway this is the i was trying
to think of like a pure bravery caption
so
me how me ordering a salad instead of a
burger
i'm not a grape
anyway here's thank you dan you can
remove that
hold on
hold on
i lost my damn no i lost my mouse hold
on i did it you [ __ ] i'm serious i'm
working on it sorry
dude get the balls off
okay hold on
oh no
this one is so
ugh
anyway here's from astroworld
back to astroworld yes
back to pigs other kinds of pigs
with small balls not big bulbs
we're really going there right now
the cops yeah they're [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] why are we talking about the cops
well i'm much about to show you the
video okay so this is 15 minutes after
the mash casualty event has been
claimed
here's the police
cbs news obtained a video from a source
[Music]
mother of god and all that is holy leave
me alone
[Laughter]
you know what they do which is really
[ __ ] up tick tock has their scroll
buttons up and down
which makes no sense why not
because i'm trying to go up and down on
this
like usually it's left and right it's
not up there well i guess
up and down
it's always been up and down here all i
do is zoom out and i'm watching a guy
eat maggots like why i didn't do i
didn't deserve this i didn't do anything
to deserve this
all right bring me this down let's
listen to this
close to the astroworld music festival
appearing to show police near the stage
during scott's performance this video
was shot at around 10 p.m with police
seemingly unaware of the severity of the
situation in the crowd
some 20 minutes after the mass casualty
event was declared the source says that
means it would be difficult for the
performers to know as well more and more
as more and more time comes out
it's becoming clear that it's the police
faults for being fuck-ups as usual [ __ ]
the police thank you pigs [ __ ] on their
own balls
[Applause]
eight people are dead and here's the
cops just on their phone
dude they have radios they have [ __ ]
walkie-talkies they got earpieces
they're there to
protect the public oh what are they
doing
what are they doing
so there's eight people today 20 minutes
i don't understand that they declare
mass casualties so do they not tell
everybody they didn't tell anyone
anything that's just so weird or what i
read was that the police chief decided
to keep the show going because he didn't
want to cause a riot by stopping it
which makes no [ __ ] sense at all
god my face like it's just a
disorganized mess
whole thing yeah so it's like dude i
mean this does take the heat off of
travis scott a little bit in my opinion
because if there's police here
not knowing what's going on then how can
you expect travis to
right am i right or am i wrong well he
could see stuff from up there
i think everyone's [ __ ] up the video
yeah it seems like there was a lot of
point of failures here and i mean i hope
it gets thoroughly investigated yeah
because i mean
it's just
i think the fbi's even involved i can't
wait to find out what happened but if
the police [ __ ] up i mean they did
[ __ ] up i don't know how much of the
responsibility falls on them but they'll
get covered up they won't be held
responsible
yeah the police really think it's a
combination because he still has
responsibility
you're right he was on the stage he
could see everything yeah and also
considering his reputation and his
background
everything together
i don't know
this person said the police were taking
selfies how were they unaware of what
was happening that's their job they had
their phones totally agree
but if these guys are unaware it's not
their fault it's whoever is above them
that's not doing their job
yeah i mean it wasn't being communicated
to them yeah i mean
not that i want to give them a pass by
any means but it just it seems like
again there were
several
stages here where things the the brakes
could have been pumped and it didn't
happen
yeah this is just
such a [ __ ] up all around everything has
to come from the top you know i mean
those guys are just doing their job too
yeah you're right i shouldn't blame
those those specific officers it's more
what was wasn't communicated to them
over the while travis is at the top
because it's his show it's his show he's
a professional artist he knows what he's
getting involved in this is on his first
show
okay first rodeo
you're right queen
oh here's a segment we've been wanting
to do for a while
the bizarre roommates stories
bizarre
bad weird roommate stories
we've been meaning to do this on off the
rails for so long
and uh
let's just do it today
are you gonna last
i can go last
no i mean like are you going to lie are
you going to laugh i'll be like sure
can i put out yeah i'll be fine can i
put aloe vera in my that's not going to
happen is good i think yeah right it's
all natural
this is first aid oh ice cream maybe ice
it's antiseptic pain relief with aloe
that should be fine right
yeah everyone's saying yeah
yeah i'll be fine
you guys just go ahead oh you say aloe
vera
hello i'm just okay
should be fine
why are you not using your fingers
i don't like the feeling that my fingers
get all icky but i'm gonna
okay one from what for one cream to
another my friends
so who wants to go first i know everyone
had pretty good stories
are you too distracted by my freak show
a little distracting
um
i'll go first
what's your weird story it doesn't
involve you did you get that
antihistamine did you like the benefit
you know i don't have many because all
every time i've lived with roommates
that's been with you
and others that's interesting
well maybe you have one of one of our
roommates but mine is from before
we lived together
isn't that cute by the way you also live
with yeah i
when i met ethan i was at the army and i
was still living with my parents 19. any
any army roommates that were weirdos
um
no
not really it's not like that
but um so
during my time at the army we met and we
kind of became close
closer and closer until it became
official
and then i just went from living with my
parents to moving in with it and it's
awesome like there was no there was no
dating in between yeah it was crazy
empty and like
we went from zero to 100 yeah first we
had to live together from the first day
and then ela we had to share bank
accounts too
yeah because she was there for a while
oh wow i got ice this is i got a whole
trios station here thank you olivia
and so we went basically yeah from
living together and sharing a bank
account from day one and it hasn't
changed since
we basically got married from the first
day you showed up
yeah
but let's see do we let's see do we have
weird stories
oh well i remember one of our roommates
left her like cat [ __ ] all over the
house yeah you want to tell that one
yeah our housemate i mean pete and we
love her she was great though
she was really good but she did have a
cat and i guess she wasn't very clean
with the cat so
at one point there was literally a [ __ ]
right next to her bed
that just stayed there for like we could
see because we would walk by her room oh
and the door would be open sometimes and
it was like a [ __ ] there that would not
be cleaned for i don't know a couple
days all day
like the shit's still there yep it's
still there oh my god she was asleep she
was going in there and sleeping and
stuff how could she not notice but it
wasn't just that it was like there was a
glitter box in the bathroom yeah and
there was just cat [ __ ] like all over
the [ __ ] it sounds like she just didn't
clean the litter box it didn't yeah no
the litter box always had poop in it so
the cat would [ __ ] on the floor next to
the litter
for some reason it didn't phase me like
that's how [ __ ] phrases for some
reason that was just the life we lived
back then yeah i mean it was like a [ __ ]
show yeah you know so everything goes
there's [ __ ] all over the floor
i mean there was little cat [ __ ]
everywhere in the house
so
yeah that's a pretty good one she was
nice though but she was nice and i'll
never forget she would do like grocery
shopping
and sometimes she would get like this
huge packages of stuff
so she had one huge package of like
granola bars or something and she would
just not touch it and then we kept like
slowly we were digging at it
well she wasn't eating it yeah no we
shared a lot she was we we were all in
good terms we yeah it was good she's
she's great if she's watching this
please don't i do like you we always
liked you we always thought you were
great just to catch it pretty epic
we never complained or anything you know
yeah
well my uh i have a story that uh has a
similar energy although uh not as bad as
cat [ __ ] but
in the sense of um
i don't i've been lucky i i've had a lot
of roommates i don't i never had like a
nightmare one that i've heard lots of
stories of people having a roommate that
it's just you know practically come to
blows with them or or do
um but i i've been
i've had a lot of roommates over the
years and they've all been great i'm
still friends with the majority of them
and the one that i have a story about is
actually one of my best friends
um so he's listening he knows
he actually does occasionally listen to
the show so and and i actually i asked
him about the story because i i asked
him if he had any pictures of what i'm
about to explain and he knows you're
sharing the story yes he does and he's
okay with it he was okay with it he
seemed to
he seemed a little tentative at first i
i made the mistake of presenting it as a
bad like we're sharing bad roommate
stories and i should i was like it's not
necessarily bad it's just like weird or
something like that anyways
so
he
he's a really funny dude very eccentric
and at the time um
he was he was a smoker as i was there
was everything i think everybody that
lived in that house was a smoker
and
he got it in his head
that he wanted to
[Music]
not just want to he actually did
save all of his cigarette packs
um and
turn them into like art by like making
like mosaics out of them so we'd like
change what brand all the time so we had
like a variety of like different ones
and then we make these cigarette like
mosaics now
i was like okay i mean that's like a
little weird but that's a kind of an
interesting creative thing to do
whatever um
so i think he made like one or two of
them
but then i don't know if it was just
laziness or distraction or whatever
but
he wasn't really making them anymore and
just saving the packs
and
eventually he wound up in his room with
i'm not kidding like
the giant oversized garbage bags like
three or four of them
full of empty cigarette packs and it was
just like all over his [ __ ] room
and people that asked like you gotta get
rid of these cigarette packs he's like
no no i'm gonna i'm gonna make more of
these or whatever it it never happened
like it just was just like one of those
forgotten projects so it's just mounds
of empty cigarette packs like spilling
out into the hallway from his room
just kind of like stacked on top of each
other uh and yeah stink to it
um
i don't know that house was pretty messy
anyways so it probably just you know the
uh the overall it's the overall musk of
the house of a bunch of uh 20 year old
guys living together yeah it's amazing
how we some of us live in college i mean
it was pure [ __ ] degeneracy like i
lived at one point with like uh
five people
well i lived in a house where there was
one two three four
four guys upstairs
and then downstairs was five girls we
didn't know each other we just moved in
it was like a wasn't that i mean it was
kind of a big house i guess but we had
like our upstairs space they had their
downstairs space and we kind of kept to
ourselves
but that upstairs
situation there was like a little living
room between the rooms there was two big
rooms and we there was two guys and two
guys
i i don't think you could find a more
disgusting
vile situation than what was going on
there like there's a picture i saw
recently of it there was like a little
table we used to play smash there all
day basically that's it and drink and
smoke
and it was like cup of noodles
leftovers
take out trays empty bottles
ash just smoke
[ __ ] filled just just so
unforgivably disgusting
just horrid i mean
horrid
[Laughter]
yeah it's hard to believe that man we
used to live like that but it didn't
even faze me at the time
you literally just sit and brush the
trash aside
so you can just say it sounds pretty
similar to the house that i was living
in that i just described i think that
that's like when you when you move out
you don't know how to take care of
yourself yeah it was the first place
that i lived after moving out and and we
were
it was actually that guy with the
cigarette packs was the reason we had
this hookup it it was a way nicer house
than
we had any business having access to it
was like a three or four bedroom house
with like a backyard like it was really
nice uh way nicer than any place i've
lived in since to be frank
uh but you know
a house like that needs maintenance you
you have to mow the lawn you have to
like
take care of it
nobody uh
like literally we lived there for a year
and a half maybe two years
never mowed the lawn never did anything
it was like the the lawn was was almost
as tall as us yeah so that reminds me
yeah we rented a house too me and my
friends a separate place
this was with uh
k and i
and um
yeah you don't think well i'm renting
this i'm not mowing the [ __ ] lawn
right well the fire marshal came to our
house
and told us our house was a fire hazard
because our yard was so unkempt oh my
god that we had to
we had to do something or be condemned
essentially right
i'm surprised that didn't happen to us
we had a neighbor who [ __ ] hated us
this guy greg and we were such an
[ __ ] stan
like because he would come around and
like kind of be like anybody taking care
of that law and be like [ __ ] off [ __ ]
you brick [ __ ] who most won
he's just trying to be like nice and
polite no he he was always very passive
aggressive but like
i mean in retrospect understandably so
like he had all of these college age
guys that were just letting the house
next to his
completely fall party it looks so bad
it's tough you're like you're struggling
to
have enough money to buy food you know
it's like you're not thinking about life
college kids for the most part are very
busy
ones that are responsible anyway
especially if you have to work i didn't
do anything let's be honest
ah
so anyone else want to go
i'll uh i'll go go ahead zach so i mean
as most people know i always lived with
my parents until i moved out recently
and i live with my girlfriend now
so this involves my best friend in the
whole world his freshman roommate in
college and i went there all the time i
crashed in his dorm a bunch of times so
call him kind of my roommate too
and this guy he he he's a
he listens to the show so uh
if you know who you are i love you man
um
he uh he he's very nice he's a very nice
guy he's from baltimore
and
he would just do some very interesting
quirky
one-off things um
like put his boots in the freezer
that's a thing guys isn't it i i guess
so it was the first time i ever i've
heard it is i've heard people put their
jeans in the freezer to clean it
because they don't want to wash it so
that lasts longer i did hear that yeah
was that was that why he did it i i
don't know it could have been
um
he uh
would leave his jerk off lube on my
friend's bed
that side
okay
yeah
um
sorry guys you're talking about like a
bottle of moisturizer or something yeah
the glue so why was it next to us his oh
we got some more medicine hang on zach
no you did fine you didn't do it yeah
so what is this so here's a banana drill
i got a drink
let's go let's od i should just get
every form of benadryl they have
a tablet
how does my face look leena
it's all happening
it's nice
she says
all right so um
let's take the banana drill here let's
do a little
first aid
um
let's see
take every to six hours
adults 12 and over take one let's take
two tablets right it says one to two
have another allergic reaction to this
like i don't think i've ever taken this
stuff so yeah one two two let's take two
let's take three
two that shit's gonna make you tired
oh no it's mixing all this [ __ ] yeah
it's dry it's trying let's party i just
thought we have some alcohol in the
fridge
what's up farm party
people are saying that the liquid works
quicker than the tablets yeah okay so
i'm doing both
i'm definitely doing them both
you shouldn't makes oh no not both
we need to
love
something to happen my face is like on
fire right now
i put the aloe and the vaseline i don't
know if you guys could see what i was
rubbing vaseline into my dome i'm with
love i don't think you should mix man
it's just alex it's just your americans
are crazy with this stuff
yeah yeah they are crazy i mean the
swedes are like you're not even allowed
to do anything over there
no you guys are very conservative with
drugs we don't give a [ __ ] i'll smoke
crack right now
okay smoke that benadryl dude love when
you come out here we're going to smoke
crack together bro i'm done
for sure we're going to get crazy
by the way
yeah i can't open this thing like it's
this child-proofed against
me right so here's what we're gonna do
guys we're gonna we're not mixing we're
gonna chug this with this no
dude you're gonna be on the [ __ ]
floor that [ __ ] makes you so drowsy
really yeah
okay sounds fun
so how much of this am i supposed to
drink is there such thing as benadryl
tripping oh yeah where you like take a
bunch and then you try your best to stay
awake can you guys just give me stuff to
make my beard stop itching white take
the pill
you'll benefit and then you'll feel not
itchy also drill trip that's what it's
called the benadryl tripping
that's what the kids are calling that's
what the kids call it you hear that love
come on over to america baby we're
having a farm party yo let's we could
share one of these together when you get
here you'll be sick i'm done it also
looks like a little
still like bring it over to the party
and then i have to pay for the health
care afterwards
that's the other thing nobody has health
care that's what makes it fun it's kind
of risky it's like
you're throwing the dice
it's called the robot just asking me to
stop you yeah
then you got to be the one yeah we don't
do that oh don't overdo it just take two
all right or no
i did it was it too late yeah he full
scent i did two with the
i thought you were kidding no i wasn't
kidding i didn't oh
i'm sorry
you guys think he's kidding okay
well i didn't drink a lot it was just it
didn't drink a lot it was just enough to
put the pills down how many pills did
you think everyone's saying you can
overdose i can overdose what how many
pills did you get everybody's
but he took the liquid form also
but not a lot just a little bit
give it a little extra you guys are fine
you got dude you guys know i [ __ ] like
this can't be the most dangerous thing
i've put in my body trust me
let me let me just know about that
warning do not
it says i stepped away i went to the
bathroom just so everybody knows and i
came back and ethan's slamming pills
wait hold on this says that it could
cause rectal before it holds up in court
oh no
i have double rectal bleeding
wait hold on this says
that's the bonus it says
it can make me drowsy
usually you read these before
you suggest
lena hands me i take
you bought it from ralph's how dangerous
can it be
[Music]
i don't
i don't know if that logic holds up
necessarily
yeah so
um
i don't know what's going to happen but
hopefully it keeps me from itching i
don't see any warnings like you'll die
yeah i don't see any like it's right
there
[Laughter]
[Music]
it says for adults and children over 12
the maximum is 300 milligrams bro i'm
not even close to that
that's 25 25 and like a little taste
in fact give me that bottle i want to
hit that again
no more please because i'm like well i'm
not even at a hundred let alone 300.
see you guys are tripping over enough
100 is good i think all right let's
continue on oh my tv doesn't work
i think the the
i just need to log in i think oh
i think the allergies is making me lose
my mind
having a rash on my brain right now
okay so where were we zach you were
telling your story yeah yeah so he he
would just do interesting things boots
in the freezer uh leave his jerk off uh
lube on my friend's bed so hold on but i
want to ask so he left his jerk off lube
on the bedside what does that imply to
you yeah no it was on his
his side i meant to say his side of the
room on his bed so what does that mean
he's jerking off on his bed it could be
but here's the the better part of this
situation was there was one time there
was a jizz filled condom no and
he would always talk about how he would
masturbate into condoms
because he said it felt better
okay i don't it's cleaner
so
he he was very he was he was very
interesting he would
almost dress like an ss officer
with like
suspenders and he was super tall
and super nice but just just out there
and you said you're still friends with
him yeah he's a great i mean once you're
not in the realm he's a nice person yeah
what's the relevance of him being tall
zach
you just look like an essay i'm giving
you a description
so any to tie this all in his dad came
to visit one time
and his dad was the coolest [ __ ] guy
and we're like oh why can't we have you
as a roommate
and so
he's like i found a picture of his dad
actually
i feel like he's gonna look like ivan
drago yeah close enough
is that who is that
an ss officer oh okay just a random
access officer
so his dad comes into town and
he is like all right you guys wait here
i'm gonna go get you something he buys
us a bottle of jack daniels and a carton
of cigarettes and he's like here you
kids go have fun
he sounds like a [ __ ] psychopath his
dad was cool we were in college we're
like oh [ __ ] this is what we want you
know it's really did that's like pure
degeneracy sounds like he'd raise a kid
that would jack off into a [ __ ] condo
that that's that's like pathetic level
parenting where he just wants to be
liked by you guys kind of whatever
that's a great paul move right there
that's such a great ball move
it was because they're under the age
wait were you guys under age yeah we
were oh my goodness
we were uh 19 19 now
wow yeah so anyways
good guy though well hold on i'm more
con i'm more worried about this though
your
dude you're friends with was potentially
jerking off he could have been someone
else's bad he could have been he very
well could have been that's gross oh it
was someone else's bed yeah it was my it
was my friend's bed because it was just
saying that he had a bottle of lube next
to his bed no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no he's tall yeah
yeah
no but like
this dude's like insanely tall oh
that's so handsome yeah yeah is he
muscular yeah
so wait did you guys ever question him
about the lube nearest homie's bed we
never questioned him about it we were
just you want to call him now
i i can hit him up yeah call him
[Music]
i'll wait
when i moved into school one year there
was a crusty sock underneath my mattress
before i put all the bedding on
hold on you say that again about the
krusty sock when i moved in one year
you i like flipped mine or the mattress
with the like the door yeah in a dorm
room oh no
there's an ancient crusty sock under
your mattress yeah better than it was
filmed
i mean
if i had an if i thought that my
roommate was jerking off of my bed i
would need to investigate that
we just rolled with the changes dude
so was it one time you found the lube
there or was it like many times it was
multiple times we found the lube one
time founding ages filled condom
not in your friend's bed
the condom was on
friend's bed
not in the garbage
it was on your friend's bed a jizz
failed condom yes
the whole story is different
how and how did you never confront him
on this i just don't understand i don't
think we could i mean it's not the
easiest conversation to bring up
are you [ __ ] kidding me bro my story
is condom on the bed that needs that
that needs to be addressed
we were like oh his dad bought us the
[ __ ] all right it's cool
whatever oh that gave him a pass yeah
jerk off in your bed yeah that's almost
like a conscious effort too to leave
that there he could have been [ __ ]
with us
i mean that's not that's beyonce that's
a prank bro yeah he probably tells the
story from his point of view like you
guys are a bunch of [ __ ] weirdos for
not saying anything
he's like i'm going to prank these guys
and then you guys just never said
anything he's like it's pretty [ __ ]
weird i'm going to pretend that's
awesome they just accepted it
were you intimidated by himself no
we were just focused on other [ __ ]
okay interesting
well for example i had a roommate once
one of my best friends
you know sometimes you have to have
uncomfortable conversations he kept
jerking off in the shower
and he would he wouldn't [ __ ] clean
the drain out and i don't i don't know
if the ladies know about like when you
know jerk off hits water it congeals it
turns to like this disgusting especially
if there's air at the drain which there
was
it would just congeal at the drain
and
stay there and it's just rancid um
and i would go in the shower after him
and there'd just be [ __ ] jizz and
hair
sitting there
and you know and the water's sitting too
because it can't it can't address that
so so i have to go into a tub full of
jit of another dude's jizz that's like
up to my ankles and i said i said look
dude i
this isn't comfortable for me but if
you're gonna jerk off in the shower you
have to clean the jizz out end the story
okay
of this dude who uh
was cleaning a pool and he was cleaning
a jacuzzi filter and he's like you guys
need to stop [ __ ] in the jacuzzi
because it's all just [ __ ] jigs
i can totally see that just destroying
the pool hardware
yeah
olivia said she had a similar story for
hers somewhat similar oh similar in that
like
something just didn't go addressed
because we didn't know how to and then
it was way too long
okay let me i'll explain
so we moved in
to an apartment there were three of us
and on the first night i really hope no
one sees it they won um on the first
night uh when i went to take a shower
the toilet was not flushed and i was
like
what was in it
it was like
i think
then it was just pee and like toilet
paper okay and i was like that's kind of
gross but whatever it's
one off i'll flush it myself and then
the next morning i went in and it was
full again
oh p again of p with toilet paper okay
and so i talked to one of my friends
because i was like is that you and she
was like
no but i did see that and then we didn't
address it because we thought that it
was a mistake or something and then we
just kept not addressing it because it
had been too long at that point so we
went the entire semester
having to take care of
her flushing for her and like even when
this is kind of gross but like when she
was on her period she would leave her
tampons right there for us oh boy
setting wait are you not supposed to
flush tampons right you're not a lot of
people do a lot of people but also
because it's so great most people if
they do flush and they flush them
themselves
you know yeah that's
not something you want to leave in the
toilet no or if you toss it you just
wrap it up you don't just
drop it in the toilet i mean in the
trash you don't need that
sometimes there would be some loose
tampons in the trash too just right on
the top
so she never had poop in the toilet
no i think what it was was she was
trying to save water yeah
about are we gonna be saving water we
met people like that in santa cruz too
well there's
don't flash to save water but i don't
know how i feel what city were you
living in ohio
is that a water do you guys have water
issues with water yeah because i mean
some cities have water issues
santa cruz does not have water because
there's plenty of water in northern
california you can flush the toilet
right
yeah yeah she also had like
i hope she doesn't see this she had
she's still one of my best friends love
her so much we just shouldn't live
together anymore um
she had this like
routine at night that obviously my
friend and i weren't aware of like how
are we supposed to know and so one of
the i think it was like the first week
we were there
she had showered and then
it was my turn it was like the last
shower of the night and i went in and i
turned on the shower i had like washed
my face and then all of a sudden i heard
like a super fast knock on the door and
i was like yes and she was like can i
please come in like i have to be i have
to pee like and i was like
oh
like can you wait like i literally just
want a shower it'll take five minutes
and she's like no no i have to and then
she explained to me that she has a
routine that she has to follow where
it's like she takes a shower she goes
upstairs she pees she goes upstairs she
comes back down has to like wash her
hands or something and then she goes to
bed and i was like
okay for sure you can absolutely do that
like do your routine that you have to
but like
maybe
don't be
super adamant about having to be the
first one to shower like if all of us
have to do it if you have like a
three-hour ritual right that has to take
place afterwards i mean that sounds like
ocd behavior yeah
no it totally does i have absolutely i
have ocd tendencies i just don't
know what it was where i was like i need
to
stop your shower from happening yeah
good thing dan said that before i said
what i was about to say no yeah yeah
yeah i mean
that is what it sounds like yeah no no
i'm glad i think i got lotion in my
mouth
i have the worst taste in my mouth it's
so bad
it's so bitter yeah why is this
happening do you feel drowsy why no no i
don't wonder why is this happening why
is there a terrible taste in my mouth is
that from the medicine i took because i
don't think i got anything in my mouth
benadryl is pretty bitter
yeah you but didn't you take a swig
no but now it's coming up like
my mouth feels numb
you swallowed a lot of benadryl yeah
that kid
they can numb your tongue
really yeah
but it's so bitter it's like it tastes
so bad oh i gotta wash my hands
legends legend show must go on
i yeah i have one let's hear yours bud
so um i may have talked about my cousin
tim before on the show i'm not sure if
you follow me like on instagram you've
probably seen him i do not endorse him
in any way if you're from my hometown
you've probably heard of uh crazymo
who's hangs out at donutville at 4 am
that's my cousin
he's always been a weird dude he comes
from a really like good family his
father was very uh well known well
respected but he's like the apple that
was thrown from the tree
he's yeah he's a little different but um
me and his younger brother and him
split rent three ways
for about four years five years in
college and he paid a third of utilities
a third of rent a third of everything
and he never slept there once
and he would he would sometimes come
there and like we'd hear like something
rustling he'd grab like some clothes and
then run out
and a lot of people are probably
assuming drugs but he never has drinking
anything in his life he's never smoked
nothing
he's just where was he staying
we think he was staying with his mother
who was living at my grandmother's house
in like the middle of the hood for some
reason we had a really nice place but he
preferred
the hood
we don't know why
you can't explain cousin tim
so whatever pre-notions you have of him
you just have to
get over him but anyways the story is
he's always doing weird [ __ ] and mean
his younger brother's normal and we kind
of just
we we don't hang out with him or
anything he just does his own thing but
thank you uh
one time we got a phone call from his
mom and saying hey have you talked to
tim he got in a fight with uh
let's just say ahmed's dad i'll just the
fake name is ahmed ahmed being one of
our best friends since we were a kid and
his dad was like very close with us we
went to like family get-togethers with
him he would bring out like the cake it
was it was a really weird phone call to
hear that he beat up one of our
childhood best friend's father because
we were so close with that family and
we're like oh what happened and
she didn't know what happened she's like
just so you know i was like okay we'll
ask him when he comes over later
and i told his brother you know what
don't say anything to him i'm curious if
he's going to tell us that he got in
this fight with ahmed's dad so tim came
over and didn't mention it whatsoever
and he's just like oh yeah we're going
to eat and we're like are you going to
tell us that you got a fight with you
know one of our best childhood friends
dads
and he's like uh oh yeah yeah he was i
don't know he was just he was talking
[ __ ] about our family so we got a fight
at the bakery
i'm like aren't you gonna acknowledge
that are you gonna tell us that what
what do you mean that's the weirdest
thing we've ever heard anyways long
story short the dad came to our house
and he was like super drunk and then
like there was this huge fight in the
middle of our front lawn
and the dad is like you know he came
from overseas he has a really strong
accent and he was screaming out some of
the most
wild [ __ ] i've ever heard and like the
phrases stuck with me
for whatever reason he kept saying
you and ahmed were best friends you came
over to my house you play pokemon you
play the pikachu you play with um as a
pokemon he kept saying pokemon with a b
because arabs we don't have a p sound in
language in our language so in english
that just goes to be
pokemon every year for his birthday he
say tim my best friend give him extra
twenty dollars you want and for some
reason he could perfectly announce
dragon ball z technician he's like you
want to play dragon ball z
i buy it for you because you're rahman's
best friend and you fight me it was just
wait why did he get in a fight
he i guess that he was talking [ __ ]
about our family because like my our
friend's dad was going through divorce
and
i think he was drunk and he was just
talking about a lot of random [ __ ] about
our family i think it was me or my other
cousins were just being like all right
whatever you know left him alone but
unfortunately he got cousin tim in the
bakery so
they got like a fist fight and mail the
bakery
and
the odd part about all this is after
they're fighting in our front lawn
screaming about takanichi and [ __ ]
pokemon
they started to make up through this
this argument
and tim's like yeah that was that was my
favorite game i loved playing that game
i'll never forget you brought it out
with this cake
and i it was just the weirdest by the
end of the day they made up and we all
went to go eat together
which is worse because i kind of hope
they would have kept fighting because
how [ __ ] awkward that that dinner was
but um
yeah i don't know if i did a good job
describing that but that's my cousin tim
and this was a roommate of yours i
missed you yeah he was he was a roommate
who never uh slept at the house he
played the third he paid a third of
everything but never showed up to have
screening matches on the front yard yeah
exactly so your cousin tim got in a
fight with your zelda's best friend
did they like hit each other just
screaming well when we were there they
were just screaming at each other but at
the bakery they threw blows at each
other interesting yeah it was a very
emotional thing
i'm starting to get a headache is that
normal
probably not
getting a headache
got a metallic freak taste in my mouth
my face is swelling to the size of a
[ __ ]
pumpkin
you might need to go to the doctor i'm
not
not gonna lie
lena said i look nice
that's very sweet of her to say
well i don't know you're sitting from
there people who sit right next to me
say i just look a little red
right it's it's misleading though i feel
like with the lights i don't know kind
of hard to tell zach's coming in for a
second
come get in come get in close
come get in close
you're swollen right here you're small
i'm swallowing on the jaw yeah and this
is all blotchy and [ __ ] it's blotchy you
need to go to urgent care dude no
come on it's not that bad i'm not going
to urgent care [ __ ] that when did the
itching start
huh when did the itching start like
basically
yeah it was itchy this morning but it
got really bad when i put the [ __ ]
itch cream on it is when everything lit
off oh was it cortisone cream yeah yeah
cortisone cream makes everything worse
in my opinion
makes everything worse you wouldn't even
say what it was you just started sliding
all right slathering it on you starting
to look like vito corleone dude no i'm
not going to use it i'm just saying i
thought we read it and everybody said it
was fine i said it's hydrocortisone yeah
be some good clickbait
you know you're gonna you're gonna
actually end up
in the hospital we can use the people
you can write not click bait
emotion that that'll that'll do it
well i have one i haven't shared it's
pretty simple okay
so
right before ela came
i needed a place to stay
i was living with a friend and he was
moving out of town so i was like all
right [ __ ] i got to find my own place on
my own which was the first time you know
and i found this place these two girls
it was a really nice house in a good
part of town remember the house by the
diner it was a great house beautiful
house they had an extra room
and i took it and you know it was nice
the girls were nice the house was nice
it was awesome the room was nice
well one of their friends
they're like hey so we have a fourth
friend there was all the rooms were full
there was only three rooms
we have a friend who is looking for a
place
and he's willing to live in the
um
the living room
in exchange he'll pay all of our bills
and utilities
and he'll just live in the living room
which is fine and we never use the
living room you walk right into the
house there's like a living room there
none of us used it we just walked up to
our own rooms
so i was like
that's fine i mean they all wanted them
to move in and
great save me some money every month
so we all lived there for about a year
no problem everything was great
and when the year's up he was a nice guy
you know i had a good rapport with him
i'd say hi whatever
when the year was up and it was time to
move out this [ __ ] never paid a
single bill
and there was like ten thousand dollars
with the utilities
not only because there was like late
fees on late fees on late fees
um we owed electric water internet and
was just so stacked up this [ __ ]
never paid anything
and i was broke you know sure and so
the you remember this because it
happened right after we moved out i
remember when i
when you found out about
bill's being still yeah the girls hit me
up and she's like yo just like i was
already moved out i was done and then
the girl messaged me and she's like yo
just so you know we each owe like three
thousand dollars because the homie never
paid the bills
and i was like [ __ ] yeah i mean i was
like what the [ __ ] i didn't have the
money first of all you know i don't know
just turn into this whole thing where i
was like i don't
i don't know about this i don't know
what to do about this situation yeah
um he's your friend
this was your idea
so did did you ever give them any money
i think i gave some money but not as
much as they wanted sure
i just couldn't afford it frankly
so that that's it that's it's not that
interesting oh he used to have sex like
super loud too and there was no
there was just i mean he's just out in
the open
what
in the living room yeah like it was late
at night so people weren't walking
around or anything
but you but it was like he was shaking
the whole damn house
it was like oh
like crazy i was like dude was it him or
that was a girl it was a girl
it didn't bother me i just thought it
was funny
holy [ __ ] bro
he was like you had a good time last
night
or somebody had a good time i don't know
if you did i didn't hear from you i
heard from her
that's it not that crazy but i was just
like
you know i thought everything was great
and then all of a sudden
this [ __ ] never paid a single
damn bill
and i and i had flashbacks too
throughout the year there the internet
would go out
and i was like hey dude um
what's up with the internet it's not
working because it was his
responsibility
and and then it would come back like a
few days he's like i don't know what's
up something wrong with it
so i'm assuming he we were you know
defaulting on the bill and he had to pay
off a little bit to get it back just to
get it reactivated yeah just enough
that's my story
it's a nightmare
thank you so much saying
your voice sounds weird because your
mouth is all swollen oh stop my voice
isn't somewhere chat is really upset
that you're not at the hospital
my voice doesn't sound weird that's
that's i don't think your voice is
normal to me but yeah
good time to do the godfather
lina you come to me you bring me this
poison oh no
everything i've done look at my face
it's blotchy it's swollen
what the what is this
i'm gonna take my my own self out to the
leg
and put myself out of my own misery
i can't continue to live like this
i've got a headache my balls they itch
my
my dick itches
my dick looks like a shrimp
like with the redness
not the size
and i say to you
and i say to you my rectum is starting
to bleed
what am i to do with this on this
beautiful friday
no school no work and here i am
[Music]
and here i am
with an itchy ass and an itchy face
[Music]
crotch rod
crash front as our good friend jeremy
likes to sing
i'm hungry too
my mouth feels like a [ __ ]
crotch rod
my mouth feels like a
sheet of sandpaper
thank you
that's
that's it
any other stores
cam you got a good one eh yeah i hope so
i think it's pretty good
but uh hi everybody
i got a story and there's some people
so sorry i coughed in the mic but
back in
2018 i had just gotten my uh second
internship at adult swim right out of
college and i just graduated so i was
excited
and uh the first time around i uh
had a bit of trouble like finding a
roommate on craigslist and everything
and then i found out that through airbnb
much like what i'm doing now
you can book an extended stay airbnb
so i found this great beautiful place uh
like not too far from work
and
i found this the guy was nice it was
beautiful interior decoration
uh the dude was 59 years old that's no
big deal to me you know whatever
he looks like a mix of iggy pop and
mr clean uh
he was like he was like old man buff and
he had like those leathery muscles to
him but he had like a shaved head all he
had in his fridge were like
apples protein shakes and those egg
white
cartons that you pour out onto the uh
onto like a pan yup there's iggy pop for
for visual age just picture him bald and
a little more uh buff too
uh
some grass
yeah he was a nice guy
he was a nice guy and everything we hung
out a few times we watched movies and
like
uh he took me out to dinner a few times
and then so
one monday
i uh
received this text from him if you want
to pull that up there you have it yep
this is an unforgettable moment for me
he texts me he goes
yeah
i'll read it in his voice too
he kind of had a bit of a southern drawl
to him
yeah
so he said uh
hold on can you pull that back on screen
uh
let's eat it at six or six thirty i
request that you do not shower clean
booty but nothing else i want to smell
you
and so i responded was that text for me
and it took a bit for him to respond so
i sent the three question marks and then
you say hit me with this the the awesome
that is a pre-written from the iphone
that's what i thought
[Applause]
uh embarrassing please excuse my mistake
and i said that's fine as long as you're
willing for me and he goes cool
so here's the thing
i suspect
that that was for me
because
i went back that night
and there was no other clean booties at
the condo
there was no other dinners being had
that night and
he like you know there's just little
things that
i put two and two together like he would
at one point before all this he said oh
you got you got such nice legs and stuff
like that and and i you know i was
innocent and i was like oh thanks man
like i appreciate it thanks bro yeah and
like you would you know there's a lot of
things that in hindsight i put two and
two together
like the time that he has to suck your
dick yeah exactly i thought you were
like wait yeah
yeah
i just thought
he was a good airbnb host you know
yeah that's that's how that went so he
he was the airbnb host
did he live there or he was just like
the yeah he owned the condo and like it
was like an extended space or you could
like sublease for a bit um
cam you have an interesting life i feel
like stuff like this happened to you
stuff does just happen to me and i'm all
here for it
i feel like he's he's one of these guys
that one day there'll be a documentary
about how he was watching everyone from
like oh [ __ ] he had a whole way to watch
everyone was your landlord buffalo bill
i swear to god that's what i said when
cam first told me this story could
someone scroll up on the text i want to
read that part again
how much longer i request that you do
not shower clean booty but nothing else
i want the smell
yeah so i mean i lived with him for
another like he was ready to eat your
ass bro yeah i mean
i i didn't have the option not to wash
my ass so you know
i just had to deal with it the awesome
one is so interesting so yeah that's the
real mystery if you go down all the way
to that
cam what the [ __ ] there it is it's kind
of a question for you
oh you have a couple of your sugar
cookies
you want to know the real kicker of it
is after all this i still gave him like
four stars as a review
it's so hard to give him a battery yeah
exactly you know yeah like the place was
great he asked me he wanted to smell me
and for me to not shower but other than
that
sometimes it takes time to process what
happened you know i was very scared in
the moment and he told me that it wasn't
for me up and down and like i don't know
i don't know yeah the real question is
what he rated your sugar cookies do you
did you have sugar what's sugar cookie
well i do remember those sugar cookies
very distinctly they're from trader
joe's and i did in fact give him some
sugar not in any not in any innuendo
sense yeah wait so
trader joe's this was out of nowhere
dude it was on a monday like i don't
know what time it was and i saw it and
my eyes went oh my god what are those
on these texts that's awesome
is it is the time stamps on there yeah
it's on there yeah
wait so you know like
was that meant for me yeah wait what
time was it was it at 10 a.m
before the show
oh yeah and there was definitely a
different change of pace pre and post
texting with him did you ever address it
like in person i talked to him in person
and he's like no that wasn't for you i
swear it's okay
so were you guys planning to eat
together at six we've we had gotten
dinners in the past together with each
other so i kind of thought nothing of it
when i first saw that
i can't believe he sent this at 10 30 in
the morning yeah that's so funny
well it was fantasizing about you dude
yeah well that was actually that was
around dinner or that was
after
lunch time because that was atlanta time
uh so it was like three hours ahead of
time
that's a great one cam yeah oh my god he
waited
oh my gosh you should read some of those
other texts he's a weird guy he waited
like three minutes in between not for
you and embarrassing and then he waited
10 minutes in between embarrassing and
please excuse my mistake
and like
i was just an intern at the time i
didn't have anybody to talk to or anyone
to like
about it i was very scared people are
calling it your air being busty exactly
and you know if you look at the date too
um i've joked that 911 came a little
early that year because it was like
the sugar cookie question was actually 9
11. yeah the sugar cookie was your
personal 911 yeah yeah well you know
when it comes to airbnbs we had that one
girl who we went there it was the first
place we stayed when we got back from
israel
and we got this airbnb
it wasn't cheap it was like 200 a night
so we expected it to be decent but it
was mold there was mold all over the
bathroom there was like hell of people
there too and it like stunk of
cigarettes
the sheets were it was just such a
nightmare that's why i think i hate
airbnb to this day yeah we've been
traumatized because we were like
people even offered to come and get us
and we were like no we got it we're
adults yeah we booked the place and it
but it was like 3am when we got there
um well anyway yeah walking into the
house it looked so creepy there was just
like beds everywhere i don't know it
just looked it was a freak show there
was beds everywhere there was and then
we went in the bathroom it was stinky
there was mold everywhere and so we left
immediately we got there at 2 a.m we're
like we can't sleep here we left at 3
a.m and the lady argued with us that we
couldn't get our money back so we had to
but my point is i didn't give i didn't
even give her one star
i was too i was too afraid of her
i didn't rate her is my point oh man the
anxiety
do you have a clean booty though
um i always keep my booty clean for elo
[Applause]
what king
i think there is
i feel like i've seen an actual
documentary yeah i've seen that too what
is it called voyage built the whole
motel
uh and put cameras in all the rooms yeah
and he was spying on everyone yeah it's
like a famous story super it's on
netflix
it's called voyer voyager i don't know
if i saw that or something else right
that's i'm not sure but there is
something like that
the one i saw the guy was in like the
air vents looking down
and his wife was in on it where did we i
think this one might be it
well anyway
anyone else
i think that's it
we got we got a whole show here how long
we've been going three hours all right
thank god guys i am a swollen headache
mess yep i'm gonna go take a shower
vacancy was the dock you were talking
about oh vacancy
according to chat that might not that
makes does that sound right that sounds
familiar
yeah it was really few people saying
vacancy or boyer or voyeur yeah i wanted
that i don't think it was boyer doesn't
vacancy sounds yeah
more like it
he wasn't like a violent person he just
wanted to see but he was a creep yeah no
he was a creep
for sure
wait no that's a horror thriller it's
not that
it was a documentary
regardless guys i'm going to go to the
hospital
not click bait
if i die some of my spirit at 3 a.m with
a ouija board
definitely what the freak what the freak
oh you know what i think the drowsiness
is hitting me now
you definitely need elo to drive home
yeah that's fine
i think the title should be chat forces
me to go to the hospital
thank god they did
chad forces me to go to the hospital
midway through the show almost died
all right thank you everybody
have a great weekend we have a leftovers
this sunday
yeah get stoked
we have the pop-up tomorrow papa
love i hope you guys go and have a lot
of fun we got the numer
new members bts members bts
bts army
for members there's a new video there
it's a great i've watched a great job
baby
thank you thank you love that content
great job
anything
else
britain is free free brittany [ __ ]
teddyfrench.com black friday sales
happening now
[Applause]
thank you everyone
we'll do the real raw ritual with more
and e.t sharing life with the ringer see
how low jimmy lee they said we wouldn't
come back but you we always do embrace
from the ashes like the phoenix on the
flex back to two
you're watching h2333
you're watching h2333
you're watching h233
you're watching h